WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
BOOK CALLED THE.
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
.
MEANING STARTED AT ONE FORTY.
CAN.
YES WERE STARTING OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO WELCOME TO THE APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TODAY
WE HAVE TWENTY TWO BILLS UP.
SEVEN OF WHICH ARE IN CONSENT
PLEASE NOT THAT ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO A. B. THIRTY ONE
SIXTY ONE HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA BY THE AUTHOR.
WE ARE ALLOWED TO MAKE TO
WITNESSES A SUPPORT INTO IN THIS
IS AN OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL.
EACH OF THESE WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MAY ADD
ON THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
BY STATING ONLY THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
GIVEN THE LENGTH OF TODAY'S
AGENDA WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
UNDER THESE TIME LIMITS OUT OF
RESPECT FOR EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
TO TESTIFY TODAY. IT'S GOING TO
BE A REALLY CRAZY MEETING YOU'LL
BE.
WILL HAVE AUTHORS IN THE NOW
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE REALLY
FLEXIBLE TODAY.
I'M AS A COURTESY TO MISTER
STONE AND HIS WITNESS SAYS I
WILL BE ALLOWING HIM TO PRESENT
OUT OF ORDER TODAY BY GOING
FIRST.
I.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE FOR BEING
HERE YOU MAY GO AHEAD AND BEGIN.
I ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB THREE
ZERO ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IT'S
MY WITNESSES COME UP I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE FLEXIBILITY.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR HEARING ROOMS
THAT ARE PROCESSES ARE NOT
REALLY SET UP.
TO.
HAVE THE PARTICIPATION OF THE
DEATH IN THE HARD OF HEARING AND
SO THAT SPECIAL ORDERS REALLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
INTERPRETER HERE. BECAUSE THIS
BILL IS ABOUT DEAFENED AND HARD
OF HEARING INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AS WE KNOW UNDER STATE LAW AND
FEDERAL LAW. THAT THEY HAVE.
BENEFITS AND RIGHTS OF ACCESS
WHICH IS VERY VERY APPROPRIATE.
BUT WITHIN OUR.
HUMAN SERVICES ARENAS ACROSS
THAT THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
DOES
THOSE RIGHTS ARE NOT ALWAYS VERY
WELL RESPECTED AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING HARD THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE. LANGUAGE ACCESS TO
ENSURE ACCESS BY EVERYONE AND WE
SEEM TO NOT ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING. SO
WHAT AB THREE ZERO ZERO SIX
WOULD REQUIRE IS A DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING COORDINATOR.
IN EACH COUNTY AND A STATEWIDE
COORDINATOR STATEWIDE MANAGER TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY.
COUNTY ORGANIZATION OR THAT
THEY.
THAT HUMAN SERVICES FUNCTIONS.
ACROSS THE STATE ARE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING AND THIS IS REALLY A CUE
WHEN IN. VERY DRAMATIC
SITUATIONS.
ONE MORE SOMEBODY'S POTENTIALLY
HAVING A CHILD REMOVED FROM THE
HOUSE AND A. AND A SOCIAL WORKER
COMES.
SHERIFF COME THAT OTHERS COME TO
TALK TO THAT FAMILY AND AND
ASSESS THE SITUATION IF THE THE
PARENTS OR EVEN A CHILD IS
DEFORE HARD OF HEARING.
IT'S NOT EASY TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO STAND UP FOR THEMSELVES
REPRESENT THEMSELVES OR GIVE.
THE COUNTY WORKERS THAN AN
ACCURATE PICTURE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND THAT COULD
DEFINITELY PREJUDICES SITUATION
MERELY BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT.
IS ENSURING THAT THAT DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING THAT EACH COUNTY
HAS PROCESS IS IN PLACE. INSURES
THAT BE THEY'RE DEAF HARD OF
HEARING CAN BE ACCOMMODATED IN
WHATEVER OF THE THE FUNCTIONS
ARE IN THEIR SOCIAL SERVICES
RUN.
I DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES IN
SPORT AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THEM. THANK YOU BEFORE WE BEGIN
WITH THE TESTIMONY AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ESTABLISH CRIME.
CAN CULTURAL.
ARE.
RUBIO.
ARE HERE.
DOCTOR CHOI HERE.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
STONE HERE.
THURMOND.
WE HAVE ACQUIRED AND YOU CAN.
EVELYN UP HASN'T WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL WE THINK
IT'S CRITICAL I'M A QUICKLY
IMPORTANT BILL. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL
WOULD LIKE TO DO.
IS DID FOR MY TIME OVER TO OUR
TECHNICAL WITNESS ON DEBRA
CATTLEMEN FROM OUR OFFICE WHO'S
BEEN WORKING WITH US TO DRAFT
LANGUAGE AND.
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATION.
I'M THINK US EVELYN MENTION MY
NAME IS DEBORAH GELMAN I'M A
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY IN OUR
OAKLAND OFFICE. HOME I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
THE ISSUE THAT I'M FOR TRYING TO
ADDRESSIN THIS BILL CAME TO MY
ATTENTION SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
WHEN WE HAD SEVERAL DEAF
CONSUMERS CONTACT ARE IN DECLINE
WITH COMPLAINTS ABOUT AND FEARS
OF LOSING THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T BEING.
EQUALLY EFFECTIVELY
ACCOMMODATED IN THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH CPS FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAD A CLIENT TO ON
WAS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WAS
REQUIRED TO GO TO PARENTING
CLASSES THE PARENTING CLASS
ISSUE WAS REFERRED TO. REFUSE TO
PROVIDE AN INTERPRETER THE
COUNTY REFUSED TO STEP IN AS
WELL THE PARENTS ENDED UP
SITTING THROUGH PARENTING
CLASSES I'M NOT ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND IT ALL WAS HAPPENING
BUT KNEW THAT IT WAS A MANDATE
AND DID IT ANYWAY.
SO AS NOT TO RISK.
REUNIFICATION.
IN ADDITION.
WE HAVE HAD CLIENTS ON.
INFORM US THAT THERE IT WAS
ACKNOWLEDGED IN THEIR FILE THAT
THERE WAS NO QUOTE NO LANGUAGE
SPOKEN IN THE HOME. ON ONLY
BECAUSE THEY SIGNED AND THAT
THERE WAS NO VERBAL
COMMUNICATION WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
PROBLEMATIC. ON A SL IS IT IS A
ROBUST LANGUAGE PALM AND THEN
FINALLY. PARENTS TELLING US THAT
WHEN THE TIME COUNTY CASEWORKERS
WERE COMING OBSERVE THEIR
INTERACTIONS WITH THEIR CHILDREN
THEY WOULDN'T BRING INTERPRETERS
ON NO IDEA WHAT WAS GOING ON
BETWEEN PARENT AND CHILD. AND ON
AND NO IDEA OF DEAF CULTURE IN
THE IMPORTANCE OF KIND OF I'M
JUST JUST ICKY LEADING AND ALSO
FACIAL FEATURES AND JUST KIND OF
ON INFERRING THINGS THAT MIGHT
BE VERY INACCURATE FROM THAT
INTERACTION.
THIS ISSUE ABOUT ON LACK OF
ACCOMMODATIONS WITH SIDE TELL
PROTECTIVE SERVICES IS WELL
KNOWN IN THE DEAF COMMUNITY THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF THE DEATH. WHICH
IS THE PRE EMINENT NAM CIVIL
RIGHTS LEGAL AGENCY AND THE
UNITED STATES ON OF BY AND FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAF. HOW THEY'VE
WRITTEN A POSITION STATEMENT ON
THE S. AND? ON THE POSITION
STATEMENT I'VE REFERS KIND OF
EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY TO LOOK
AT THE.
L. A..
.
THE LA COUNTY DEPT SERVICES UNIT
FOR A MODEL AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THIS
BEAUTIFUL MODEL IN LA. THEY HAVE
A SPECIAL UNIT THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR FAMILIES WHO
ARE DEAF ON THEY HAVE FIVE TO
SEVEN CASE WORKERS WHO ARE
FLUENT IN SIGN. ON PEOPLE DEATH
FAMILIES WHO COME THROUGH THE
SYSTEM OUR SIDE SPECIFICALLY TO
THOSE CASE WORKERS.
AND SO WE TRY TO DO THAT WITH
THIS BILL.
I'M ALSO THE ISSUE OF
ACCOMMODATING PARENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WAS INVESTIGATED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN
THEY ARE WHO THEY AUTHORED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCOMMODATING ON
PARENTS WITH DISABILITIES IN
PARTICULAR DEAF PARENTS.
ON THAT IS ON A THAT'S A
WONDERFUL REPORTS AND THAT THE
GOAL WAS.
TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO LOCAL
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES AND
COURTS ON WHAT NEEDS TO BE
ACCOMMODATED PARKS HIS ME HOW
BEST TO ACCOMMODATE.
SO AS ASSEMBLY ON. A PERSON
STONE MENTIONED THAT THE LIES
REALLY CLEAR THE LAST BEEN
AROUND FOR AWHILE ON BUT
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES THE LIES
AND IMPLEMENTED THE WAY THAT IT
SHOULD. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS AHMED HOPES TO ADDRESS AND OF
OVERSIGHT ON ENSURING PEOPLE
DON'T FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
THAT WHEN THEY'RE COMMENTED
THERE COMMENTED. ON NOT JUST THE
FIRST TIME THAT THEY INTERACT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT BUT THERE
COMMENTED IT EVERY SINGLE TIME.
THAT THERE IS SOMEONE WHO
THERE'S CONSISTENCY AND WHO
THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH.
THERE'S ADEQUATE TRAINING ON
DEAF CULTURE AND OPTIONS FOR
ACCOMMODATIONS.
AND.
AND ALSO THAT THEY'RE
COMMUNICATING WITH SOMEONE WHO
EITHER IS FLUENT IN SIGN
THEMSELVES OR IS IS YOU KNOW
ACKNOWLEDGES THEY NEED TO BRING
OUT AN INTERPRETER. AND SO
COMMUNICATION REMAINS EQUAL AND
EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JEALOUS I
SERVE ON CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THE STATE
COUNCILS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SANDERLING FROM THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
CLEARLY HAVE A SUPPORTING
CONCEPT ON THE LEGISLATION WE
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT AGREE. THAT
ENSURING THAT THE ACCOMMODATIONS
AND ACCESS OR THERE IS CRITICAL
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS ACTIVE WE ON A FEW
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT WORK
TECHNICALLY ON THE GROUND. I'M
CONFIDENT WE'LL GET THERE.
IT HAVE NO ISSUES AT ALL WITH
THE BILL MOVING FORWARD AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
COME ON AND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
YEAH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY. THING THEN CAUGHT
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
UP TO TRY.
THANK YOU I HAVE.
.
SOME ANALYSES TO HEAR IS SAYS
SO.
LOVE THIS SERVICES ARE ALREADY
OUT EXISTING IS OUR LACK OF OUR
COMMUNICATION Y. MIS
UNDERSTANDING TO TO THEIR LACK
OF A PROPER O. INTERPRETERS SO
AND THE LANGUAGE OF PROVIDERS
SAID HAS BEEN DEEMED THE.
DISCRIMINATORY. BY BOTH THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL LAWS.
AND THIS.
THERE IS ALREADY OUT THERE
ACCESS A PROGRAM WITH INDEED.
.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THEN AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL
COUNTY AGENCIES SO TO YOU IS A
LIE SO HOW DO YOU ANSWER TO THIS
OUR OUR WHY WHY YOU APPEAR THIS
UNNECESSARY IF FOR.
A SERVICES IS ALREADY AVAILABLE.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT REALLY.
AVAILABLE AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE
SERVICES ARE NOT BEING PROVIDED.
IMAGINE.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THAT SOCIAL
WORKER GOES INTO A HOME WITH THE
POTENTIAL OF REMOVING A CHILD.
AND THAT FAMILY ONLY SPEAKS
SPANISH ONLY SPEAKS TO DOLLARS
ONLY SPEAKS RUSSIAN ONLY SPEAKS
CHINESE. AND THE SOCIAL WORKER
THEN DECIDES THAT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T UNDERSTAND DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON. THEY MAY REMOVE
THAT CHILD.
SAME SAME CIRCUMSTANCE HERE WE
PROVIDE TRAINING WE PROVIDE.
CULTURAL COMPETENCY WE PROVIDE
LANGUAGE
PROVISIONS BUT NOT FOR THE DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING. ASL IS A
LANGUAGE THAT NO HARD OF HEARING
DO IN FACT COMMUNICATE WHETHER
IT'S PARENTS OR OR CHILDREN. AND
IN ACROSS THE COUNTIES.
THESE SERVICES DON'T ALWAYS
EXIST TO TRAINING START ALWAYS
THERE THE PROTOCOLS ARE NOT
ALWAYS THERE WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS ENSURE THAT IN EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY. THERE IS A DEFINITE HARD
OF HEARING COORDINATOR TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE SERVICES HAPPENED AND
THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL
PROVIDING TRAINING.
MATERIALS.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE COUNTIES
TO ENSURE THAT THAT CAPACITY
EXISTS IN EVERY SINGLE COUNTY.
I THINK GOES HOW MINIMUM I'M NOT
REALLY FAMILIAR IN THIS AREA I
DO A DIFFERENT NOT SIGN
LANGUAGES UP BASED UPON THE
ORIGIN OF THE.
LANGUAGE APPLY DIFFERENT.
A CULTURE ENGLISH SO HAVE
RUSSIAN FOREIGN JAPANESE THERE
ARE THERE TEND TO BE DIFFERENT.
INTERPRETATIONS ARE DEVELOPED
DIFFERENT IMPLEMENTATIONS OF OF
SIGN LANGUAGE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ACUTE THE ISSUE
IS WITH SIGN LANGUAGE WITH A.
SPANISH SPEAKING FAMILY RUSSIAN
SPEAKING FAMILY BUT I'M TALKING
ABOUT SPOKEN LANGUAGE.
WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH THAT WE GO
SOLVE THAT BUT WHEN A FAMILIES
USING ASL AMERICAN SIGN
LANGUAGE.
AND A SOCIAL WORKER COMES
A SHERIFF'S DEPUTY COMES THERE
THERE'S AN INTERACTION WITH THE
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES AND
NOBODY'S TRAINED IN AMERICAN
SIGN LANGUAGE. THEY'RE NOT
SENSITIVE TO THE ISSUES OF A
FAMILY THAT IS USING AMERICAN
SIGN LANGUAGE OR COMMUNICATING
BECAUSE ONE OR MORE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT WHAT WE DON'T WANT
IS FOR THEM TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION THAT JUST MERELY
BECAUSE. THEY'RE COMMUNICATING
IN A DIFFERENT FORMAT.
THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM THERE.
SO YOU BEER OR CREATE ON THE
MANAGER.
DEAF SERVICES THE MANAGER AND
THEN ALSO EVERY COUNTY POSITION
ONE HAVE A DEAF AND HARD TO
HEARING COORDINATOR. AND THE
DISTAL MANAGES AND COORDINATOR
SO WHERE SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS
AT THAT GOT UP ABOUT.
IT WILL GO ALONG WAY TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEMS YES AND IN AND
INCREASE THE AMUNT OF KNOWLEDGE
AND CAPACITY WITHIN EACH COUNTY.
TO ADDRESS THE DEATH AND ART OF
HERE'S TAM IS THAT IT HAS NOT
WILL NOT BE THE REDUNDANT
SERVICE.
OKAY OUR HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION SIDE MATTHEW.
LARA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. AYE THE
MOTION BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND UGLY
AND SECOND THAT MOTION THANK YOU
CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
I'M SORRY JOIN A CLOSE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
RUBIO. REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
OKAY HER GO WITH I DON'T KNOW I
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN. REYES.
STONE BY STONE AYE THURMOND.
THREE VOTE NEED TO ONE MORE.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL AND IT'S.
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
TAKING CARE.
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK CARE.
NO QUE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
.
THINK INMIGRANTES COMMENT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO PROVIDE
UPON. REQUEST WILL LABOR
ORGANIZATION A RECORD OF ALL THE
NAMES THE NAMES AND PHONE
NUMBERS OF NEWLY REGISTERED OR
RE REGISTERING HOME CARE AIDES.
THE BILL PROHIBIT A LABOR
ORGANIZATION FROM SHARING
AREUSING THIS INFORMATION FOR
ANY
PURPOSE OTHER THAN TO PLAY
TRAINING ORGANIZING
REPRESENTATION. AND ASSISTANCE.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
PRIVATE HOME CARE AIDES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THESE PERSONAL CARE PROVIDERS
ARE PRIMARILY EMPLOYED BY LARGE
COMPANIES THAT THE PLAY HOME
CARE AIDES TO THE ELDERLY.
CONVALESCENCE OR PERSONAL
DISABILITIES WHO NEED ASSISTANCE
WITH ACTIVITIES OR DAILY LIVING
SUCH AS HOUSEKEEPING. MEAL
PREPARATION OTHER PERSONAL CARE
SERVICES.
THE WORKFORCE IS COMPOSED OF
PRIMARILY WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND THE WORK IS OFTEN
ISOLATED AND AT TIMES UNSAFE.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
HOME CARE SERVICES CONSUMER
PROTECTION ACT REQUIRE DSS TO
LICENSE PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT
PROVIDE PRIVATE PAY. HOME CARE
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA'S ELDERLY
AND DISABLED POPULATION AS WELL
AS CERTIFIED INDIVIDUAL HOME
CARE AIDES WERE EMPLOYED BY
THESE COMPANIES.
DSS RESPONSIBLE FOR COMPILING
AND MAINTAINING A REGISTRY OF
HOME CARE AGENCIES AND AIDS ON
ITS INTERNET WEBSITE.
CURRENTLY SOMEONE VISITING THE
HOME CARE A REGISTRY IS ONLY
ABLE TO VERIFY WHETHER OR NOT A
HOMECARE AIDE IS REGISTERED
WANTS A FULL NAME AND THE
PROVIDERS PERSON OF PERSONNEL.
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER ENTERED
THIS ASSUMES A CONSUMER HAS
OBTAINED THIS INFORMATION TO THE
COMPANY WHICH IS NOT ALWAYS THE
CASE.
WITHOUT A REAL WAY FOR LABOR
ORGANIZATION'S OUTREACH TO HOME
CARE IS TO OFFER TRAINING
REPRESENTATION.
THE LONG TERM CARE WORKFORCE
COULD BE STUNTED A TIME WHEN
THERE'S A GROWING POPULATION OF
SENIORS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AB FIFTY
THIRTEEN WHICH WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN.
THAT HOME CARE AIDES ENTERING
THE SYSTEM WERE NOT AWARE THAT
THE INFORMATION WOULD EVENTUALLY
YOU DISCLOSE LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS.
HAVE ADDRESSED THOSE CONCERNS BY
MAKING AB TWENTY FOURTH FIVE AT
PROACTIVE PROSPECTIVE MEASURE.
THAT NOTIFIES THE NEWLY
REGISTERED OR RE REGISTERING
HOME CARE AIDES TO THE
REGISTRIES AVAILABLE TO LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS.
I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT ADD
TO THE FACTS OF BINDING SECTION
AND REPLICATE AGREED UPON
LANGUAGE OF LAST YEAR'S AB
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN. REGARDING THE
WRITTEN NOTICE TO HOME CARE
AIDES ABOUT THE NEW DISCLOSURE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE GRANTS
HOME CARE IS OPPORTUNITY TO
BENEFIT FROM TRAINING AND
ORGANIZING THAT MAY NOT BE
READILY AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THESE SERVICES CAN HELP HOME
CARE AIDES ADVANCE THEIR
CAREERS.
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF CARE THEY
PROVIDE AND EARN INVALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE STATE
SHOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AS OUR
AGING POPULATION CONTINUES TO
INCREASE.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTS MY OUR TIFFANY WOULDN'T
FROM SEIU CALIFORNIA. AND
DANIELLE DAVIS A PRIVATE HOME
CARE WORKERS.
THANK YOU BYE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TIFFANY
RIGHT NOW WITH THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
REPRESENTING OVER THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND LONG TERM
CARE WORKERS WHO LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR IT. ON THE FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THE AMENDMENTS I'M THAT WERE
LAID OUT AND SAID THAT ANALYSIS
I JUST WANTED TO ECHO IN NOTE
I'M REALLY QUICKLY THE CHANGES
THAT WERE MADE FROM LECTURES
VERSION THAT YOU GUYS THOUGHT.
TO THIS YEAR'S VERSION IT ONLY
AFFECTS THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NEWLY
REGISTERED OR WHEN THEY GO TO
RENEW THEIR REGISTRATION EVERY
TWO YEARS.
SO WE LOOKED INTO THE VETO
MESSAGE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
MADE.
THE PROPER CHANGES TO AND SO
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DANIELLE
ONE OF OUR.
MEMBERS THAT CAN SPEAK FROM THE
CARE GIVERS PERSPECTIVE.
.
THANK YOU.
HOW LOW CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DANIEL
DAVIS FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE BEEN A
PRIVATE AGENCY HOMECARE PROVIDER
FOR OVER THIRTEEN YEARS WITH THE
INSTITUTE OF AGING?
I LOVE MY JOB EVERY DAY I HAVE
GREAT OPPORTUNITIES TO GIVE LOVE
COMPASSION AND SERVICES THAT
HELP PEOPLE LIVE A MORE
INDEPENDENT LIFE BECAUSE. I HELP
THOSE WHO CANNOT FULLY HELP
THEMSELVES.
THOUGH MY WORK CAN BE
CHALLENGING SOMETIMES I JUST
FOCUS ON PROVIDING THE BEST CARE
THAT I CAN AND ALWAYS REMEMBER
THAT THE PATIENTS APPRECIATE MY
WORK. THEY ARE MORE LIKE FAMILY
TO ME THAN JUST PATIENTS.
I'M ALSO.
EXCUSE ME I AM ALSO ABLE TO
FOCUS ON THE CARE I GIVE TO
CLIENTS BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT I
HAVE
FROM MY UNION. SINCE I BEGAN MY
CAREER WITH THE INSTITUTE ON
AGING I HAVE PASSED THE SUPPORT
I NEED FOR MY UNION BUT NOT ALL
CARE GIVERS ARE AS LUCKY AS ME.
BUT WE ALL ARE ONE AND WE ALL DO
THE SAME JOB AS THE SHOP STEWARD
I TAKE WHAT I DO AND THE CARE I
PROVIDE VERY SERIOUSLY.
I ADHERE TO MY OWN STRICT
STANDARDS TO KEEP MY CLIENTS AND
MYSELF SAY.
STANDARDS THAT I HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO LEARN AND TEACH OTHERS
BECAUSE I AM CONNECTED WITH MY
CO WORKERS AND HAVE AN EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVE THAT I CONTRAST.
I SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE BECAUSE THE IDEA
OF ALLOWING SPECIFIC LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS TO REACH OUT TO
CARE GIVERS LIKE NEED. TO HELP
THEM BECOME A BETTER CAREGIVER
WITH THE RESOURCES THAT MAY NOT
BE PROVIDED OTHERWISE.
THAT MAY NOT BE OTHERWISE KNOWN
TO THEM SKEWS WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PLACED IN YEARS AGO.
ON BEHALF OF PRIVATE AGENCY HOME
AIDS AND THE PEOPLE WE CARE FOR
WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE AND RESPECTFULLY
ACTS FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHE BONDED AMONG
BECAUSE WITH UT W. OFFICE ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY.
AB WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
THIS DOES.
HELLO MY NAME IS APRIL CARNEY
I'M WITH APEX CARE AND HOME CARE
SERVICES I AM STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
.
LET ME AMEND JERRY MEMBERS BRAVE
NEBRASKA MAP THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH SERVICES AT
HOME.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
OFFER SMALL.
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE PROPOSED.
DOESN'T CHANGE UNFORTUNATELY
DOESN'T CHANGE OUR POSITION ON
THE BILL.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'M GONNA
START BY SAYING THAT COST IS NOT
AGAINST UNIONS WE HAVE NOTHING
AGAINST OUR HOME CARE WORKERS
JOINING THE UNION.
WHAT WE DO OBJECT TO THOUGH IS
THE STATE?
DOING WHAT THE UNIONS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THE UNITS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO ORGANIZE HOME CARE ALL
WORKERS FOR YEARS THEY HAVE BEEN
THEM TO DO IT IN THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO HAVE THE STATE DO IT
FOR THEM.
.
YOU JUST HEARD SAYING THAT THIS
IS THE ONLY WAY TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO HOME CARE
WORKERS THAT ISN'T THE CASE.
YOU CAN DO NEWSPAPER ADS YOU CAN
DO MAGAZINE ADS YOU CAN DO
INTERNET.
YOU CAN GO ON TO THE REGISTRY
AND GET THE NAMES. AND ADDRESSES
BY COUNTY OF HOME COURT OR
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND VISIT THEM THERE LOTS OF
WAYS TO REACH OUT TO HOME CARE
WORKERS WITHOUT GETTING PERSONAL
NAMES PERSONAL PHONE NUMBERS AND
CELL PHONE NUMBERS OF THE
STATE'S.
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT I JUST US
WORKERS THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WORKING
FOR DR RACE THIS BILL IS ABOUT
REGISTERED HOME CARE AIDES
WORKING FOR REGISTERED HOME
CARRIED COMPANIES.
HOME CARE ORGANIZATIONS HAD TO
BE REGISTERED STARTING TWO YEARS
AGO THEY'RE JUST GOING TO THEIR
RENEWAL PROCESS NOW.
BECAUSE ACTUALLY SUPPORTED
LICENSURE WE ACTUALLY PROPOSED
LICENSE YOUR BILL OURSELVES
WORKED WITH VARIOUS ENTITIES
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR HOMECARE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND A HOME CARE
AIDES OF WORKING OFF THE SAME
CRITERIA.
WE DEMANDED AS PART OF LICENSURE
THAT TRAINING BE PUT INTO
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS HOME CARE
AIDES HAVE TO MEET THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS OF TRAINING. EVERY
YEAR.
THAT TRAINING MUST BE DETAILED
BY THE TYPE OF TRAINING. WHAT
WAS COVERED IN THE TRAINING THE
NAME OF THE COURSE AND THE
INSTRUCTOR THAT WAS GIVEN THE
COURSE?
EVERY TWO YEARS THE DEPARTMENT
COMES OUT AND REVIEWS HOMECARE
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY LOOK AT THAT TRAINING FOR
EVERY SINGLE AID THAT THE
COMPOUND SEE.
IF THAT TRAINING IS NOT THERE
THE HOMECARE ORGANIZATIONS FACE
A FINE OF UP TO NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY PER VIOLATION.
THAT'S NO SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT COULD QUICKLY PUT HOME CARE
ORGANIZATION OUT OF BUSINESS IF
THEY'RE NOT IN COMPLIANCE.
WE TAKE TRAINING VERY SERIOUSLY
AND TO SAY THAT HOME CARE AIDES
ARE NOT GIVING TRAINING CRAP
FRATERNITIES IS SIMPLY FALSE.
ADDITIONALLY.
WHAT IS THIS BILL DOING ITS
PROVIDING FOR ONE GROUP OF
PEOPLE? PRO UNION FOLKS TO GET
ACCESS TO INFORMATION TO PROVIDE
SPEECH.
WHERE ANOTHER GROUP FOR EXAMPLE
AND ANTI UNION ORGANIZATION DOES
NOT GIVE THAT SAME INFORMATION
TO PROMOTE THEIR OWN SPEECH?
IF THIS INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
TO A PUBLIC INFORMATION REQUEST
IT SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
BOTH SIDES NOT JUST ONE SIDE
WITH THAT WE ASK FOR AN OF.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS THAT CARL
LONDON HERE ABOUT THE HOME CARE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA WE ALSO
REPRESENT. NUMBER OF PRIVATE
BUSINESSES THAT PROVIDE HOME
CARE SERVICES THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE AGREE. WITH THE OF
PRIOR TESTIMONY THE PRINCES OF
THIS BILL ARE JUST FALLS.
THIS BILL IS PURE AND SIMPLE.
ABOUT NOTHING MORE THAN
ORGANIZING IN HANDING OVER TO
ORGANIZED LABOR THE TOOLS TO
HAVE ALL OF THE NAMES AND PHONE
NUMBERS OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ON THE REGISTRY REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. TO GIVE THEIR
PRIVATE CONTACT INFORMATION OF
THEM AWAITED THEM AT PURE AND
SIMPLE THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE
REASON FOR THE BILL. TRAINING
ABSOLUTELY FALSE
AS A BRAIN INDICATED BE
TRAINING.
THAT ARE ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
IS REQUIRED BOTH UNDER LAW IT'S
AN FOR QUALITY PURPOSES MINUTES
ALSO DON'T FOR LIABILITY REASONS
THERE'S NO WAY. AN ORGANIZATION
WOULD SEND
A STAFF PERSON OUT WITHOUT
ADEQUATE TRAINING FOR FEAR OF
LIABILITY IMPROV'S THAT WOULD
ARISE FROM THAT. LAST YEAR I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT WE
HAD VICTIMS.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS WHO
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION THIS
BILL THEY'RE VERY AFRAID OF
HAVING THEIR INFORMATION
CIRCULATING ANYWHERE. THEY DID
NOT WANT TO SEE IT CIRCULATING
IN A WHERE WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE OPT OUT WAS GIVEN AS A
CHOICE BUT AT MINIMUM.
AND THE WOMEN THAT TESTIFIED
WERE ASKING FOR AN OPT IN THIS
BILL DOESN'T DO THAT. THAT SAID
THAT WOULDN'T SATISFY
ORGANIZATION WE SEE NO
COMPELLING REASON TO DO THIS.
THE OTHER THING THE BILL
PROVIDES ABSOLUTELY. NO
LIMITATIONS WHATSOEVER ON THE
TYPES OF CALLS THE NUMBERS OF
CONTACTS THAT CAN BE MADE TO
PERSONS ONCE INFORMATION IS
GIVEN AWAY. THEY COULD BE
REPEATEDLY HARASSED CONTACTED
OVER OVER AGAIN THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE BILL. THAT RESTRICTS THAT
IN ANY WAY.
FINALLY LOOKING AT A OTHER
EXAMPLES.
IT'S IT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE THAT
OTHER STATES THERE HAVE BEEN
EFFORTS TO TRY TO ON ORGANIZE
WORKERS.
WHEN THOSE TYPES OF LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED.
GUESS WHO OPPOSES THOSE LABOR
UNIONS THEY DO NOT WANT TO SEE
YOU EQUAL INFORMATION PROVIDED
TO THE PEOPLE THAT THEY WORK
WITH.
LAST THING ITS IN THIS IS
COMPARE THIS TO.
ANY OTHER PERSON REGISTERED WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE YOUR PHYSICIAN YOUR
DENTIST. A ANY PERSON WAS A
LICENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE NOT NO PERSON
IS ABLE TO CONTACTED THAT
LICENSING BOARD AND ASK FOR YOUR
DOCTORS HOME PHONE NUMBER AND
CONTACT INFORMATION. IF THEY
CHOSE TO GIVE IT TO THAT'S FINE
YOU COULD GET IT BUT THERE IS NO
OTHER STATE PRECEDENT FOR THIS
WERE GIVING AWAY INFORMATION TO
A SINGLE. POPULATION OF PEOPLE
JUST FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ORGANIZING AND AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT WE
ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE THIS WEEK
URGING NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
AND.
HAPPEN ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THEM.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RAINY POLLOCK IN
BEHALF OF HOME INSTEAD IN
OPPOSITION.
ALLAN FISHER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION HONOR OF INTO CARE IN
HOME CARE.
KAREN KAUFMAN.
OWNER OF INTO CARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
FAIRLY NARROW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
AHMED CHAIR KEVIN PROUTY
REPRESENTING MAXIM.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THINK YOU.
WITH THAT AYE ACTION THERE'S
NOT OKAY.
YES.
WHO? WHO? I'M.
NICOLE BARS AUG IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU
ANY COMMUNITY RELATIONS MANAGER
WITH APEX CARE AND
CARE AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
PAGE EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
CAPE MEN CHAIR IF I MAY JUST ADD
ONE MORE WITH A SECOND KLEIN
AMONG A TESTIFIED JUST IDENTIFY
THEM BUT. THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING A INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT THIS
BILL IS IS ALSO OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH THAT.
UP UP TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR TRIED.
I HEAR VERY CLEARLY THAT OF THIS
SYSTEM NOT TEMPT TO ARE NOT
ORGANIZE OUR IN HOME CARE.
SERVICE OF PROVIDERS SO.
IT MAY BE GOOD STUFF ARM. AND
FOR THE.
UNIONS TO ORGANIZE.
FOR WHATEVER CLAIM SO YOU YOU
ARE MAKING A SUCH AS TRAINING
ETCETERA BUT THE.
ALREADY I HEAR THAT THE
TRAINING IS PROVIDED AND THAT WE
WERE REQUIRED FOR. AND A WHAT
OTHER BENEFITS VIA.
HOME CARE OF RECIPIENTS SO WE
RECEIVE OUR OF THIS BILL.
WELL THIS IS BEING DONE FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE WORKER THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT AND AND.
YES UP THESE FACILITIES THERE
OF THESE COMPANIES AT THE DO A
MINIMUM OF FIVE HOURS A YEAR OF
TRAINING AS IS WHAT'S REQUIRED.
AND.
ALTHOUGH.
THAT'S A BARE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT THE REALITY IS THAT.
IN WORKING WITH OTHER LABOR
ORGANIZATION THAT SPECIALIZES IN
THIS KIND OF THESE KIND OF
SERVICES NOT ONLY. TO THE
WORKERS HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET EVEN MORE AND THE MORE
TRAINING AND THE BEST QUALITY
TRAINING THEY CAN POSSIBLY GET.
OF THE TRAINING WILL BE IS
LIMITED STRICTLY TO ISSUES OF
OUR.
OF THE JOB AND LIMITING THE
LIABILITY BUT IT WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE RIGHTS RESPONSIBILITIES
AS A WORKER AS WELL AS A WRITER
AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
EMPLOYER. CHRIS SUPPORT NETWORK
WITH THE WORKERS WELL BEING AND
MIND.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT FOR
MANY OF THE COMPANIES ARE THOSE
THAT THAT HAVE CONCERNS IF
THEY'RE TREATING THEIR WORKERS
WELL PAIN THE MILE THAT THERE.
IF THEY'RE MAKING SURE THEY'RE
PROPERLY TRAINED.
THERE'S NINE ISSUE REALLY THIS
IS TARGETING THOSE COMPANIES OR
THOSE INDIVIDUAL WORKERS WERE A
VICTIM OF COMPANIES THAT ARE OF
THAT ARE.
THE EMPLOYEE WAGE THEFT OF OR IS
NOT NOT PROVIDING SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THERE'S THE
ABILITY OTHER HAS A LOT OF
ISOLATION.
AND SO. THE IDEA BEHIND THIS IS
REALLY TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WORKERS TO BE
ABLE TO NOT ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO
ANY BUT TO BE REPRESENTED. I YOU
KNOW IT'S I THINK SOMETIMES.
WAIT WE'D.
I PRESUME THAT IT'S A IT'S AN
EASY TASK
FOR UP LABOR ANY OTHER
ORGANIZATION JUST TO GO IN AND
ORGANIZE A REALITY IS THAT THESE
WORKERS THAT.
THAT IT'S SHOWN ARE NOT ONLY IS
THERE RAMPANT WAGE THEFT AND
INDUSTRY BUT THERE'S ALL THEIR
ALSO A NUMBER OF COMPANIES I
DON'T DO ADEQUATE TRAINING EVEN
IF THEY DO THE FIVE. HOURS A
MINIMUM.
WHEN SO.
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN
ORDER TO ENSURE UPS AND THAT'S
ALMOST ONE TO KEEP MY ONE A
PREFACE THIS BY TWO THINGS ONE
IS. THE ORIGINAL BILL WAS
BROADER THAN JUST LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS HAD MORE OR ANY
WILL USE THAT TO TRAINING.
ALLEGE COUNCIL AYE ADVISE THAT
WE KNOW IT.
THE AND WE TOOK SUGGESTIONS
BOTH FROM LEDGE COUNCIL AS WELL
AS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS HOLDERS
AND OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
OTHERS OF COLLEAGUES OF MINE. TO
NARROW IT OF THE GOVERNOR VETOED
IT BE VETOED IT BECAUSE IT WAS
RETROACTIVE AND NOT A
PROSPECTIVE AYE IT'LL CLINTON'S
WE'VE CHANGED THE BILL. TO MAKE
IT PERSPECTIVE GAVE IT PASSED TO
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE LAST
YEAR BEFORE THOSE CHANGES AND
I'M HOPING THAT THESE CHANGES
BLOW UP ALLOW THE GOVERNOR TO
FOR THE KINDLY UPON.
ANOTHER AREA THAT I AM REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS IS SO.
ONCE WE PROVIDE A CERTAIN EASY.
OUR OPPORTUNITY TO FILE FOR THE
UC CARE GIVERS TO UNIONIZE SO.
MOSTLY.
THE LABOR UNIONS ARE ARE THERE
FULL WITH THEIR WELFARE.
NAM PROPER TREATMENT OF FROM
THEM PEARL YEARS ETCETERA
ETCETERA.
WHEN.
DURING THE HOT NEGOTIATION.
FOR WHATEVER CONTRACT IMPLEMENT
HELL.
A CONTRACT OR OR WE EACH
INCREASE WHATEVER WHENEVER YOU
KNOW.
IT TO SUCH A TIME NOEL GREENLAND
DOT HAS REACHED A.
THEN THE ONE OF THE TOURS SO
THAT THE LABOR UNIONS YOU SO.
THAT YOU INACTION.
TYPICALLY.
.
NAY A STRIKE.
THEN IF FAR THEY USE THAT. TYPE
OF EXTREME MATCH YOUR.
WHEN THAT ON COME TO AN
AGREEMENT.
WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO HUNDRED PERCENT RELY UPON
CARE GIVERS AND THAT THE OUT ON
HOW THE A STRIKE?
WELL WHAT WOULD THESE PEOPLE BE
TAKEN CARE WELL FIRST OF ALL
THERE ARE STILL THERE ARE PLENTY
OF HOME CARRIES AS WAS ALLUDED
TO BY SPIES SOME FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION THAT ARE YOU KNOW.
AND THERE ARE PLENTY OF FOR
COMPANIES THAT DO HAVE UNION
LABOR AND SO.
THERE'S NO ONE THAT CARES MORE
ABOUT THE ONES THAT THEY CARE
FOR THAT THE ACTUAL WORKERS BUT
I'LL TELL YOU THIS THAT IF THE
WORKERS ON CARE FOR WERE NOT
BENEFITING THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ANYWAY. AT THE WORKERS ARE BEING
OVERWORKED THAT ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED THAT THERE'S WAIT
STEPPED INVOLVED THEN WE'RE NOT
TO CARE THAT WORK WAS ACTUALLY
TAKING CARE OF THE PERSON THAT'S
A NEED.
SO. YOU KNOW THIS IS CERTAINLY.
OF THE THERE THAT THE ISSUE OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING EMPOWERS
INDIVIDUALS OTHERWISE ARE NOT
EMPOWER THAT DON'T HAVE THE
POWER AGAINST A COMPANY. AND SO
ABSOLUTELY THAT THOUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS USED TO
NOT JUST EMPOWER THE WORKER BUT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE IN THE
BEST POSITION TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR LOVED ONES WHEN THEY'RE
NEEDED.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I HAVE HAD SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
SPONSOR AND THE AND THE AUTHOR
AND I STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS
OVER.
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE AND I?
SPECIFICALLY ASKED ABOUT THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUE I
SHARED.
COMMENTS ABOUT.
.
ABUSERS.
CALLING.
THERE THERE'RE SPOUSES OR.
WHEN SPOUSES ARE RECEIVING
PHONE CALLS THE ABUSERS UP
AUTOMATICALLY REACH OUT AND I
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF I'VE MY OWN
SISTER WHO WAS A VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHE RECEIVED A
PHONE CALL AT TEN PM. AYE IT WAS
A BUSINESS CALL AND HER ABUSER
WAS.
VERY UPSET WITH HER BECAUSE SHE
WAS RECEIVING PHONE CALLS FROM
STRANGE PEOPLE AND THAT WAS THAT
A BIG ISSUE FOR ME WHEN WE HAD
THE DISCUSSION IN MY OFFICE
ABOUT. WHAT MY CONCERNS ARE?
I HOPE THAT WE CAN. ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
NOW I. WILL CAN YOU PLEASE MOST
CERTAINLY THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
LIMITED THE USE OF THE OF OF
JUST THE NAME AND THE PHONE
NUMBER THAT THEY PROVIDE TO THE
REGISTRY AS THE ONLY MEANS OF
CONTACT AND ONLY PURPOSE A
CONTACT US FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THEIR LEGITIMATE. PURPOSES FOR
THE LABOR ORGANIZATION WHICH
WOULD BE TRAINING ORGANIZING
REPRESENTATION
I ANYONE THAT'S MILLION WHO
THAT'S GOING TO VIOLATE THE LAW
AND CREATE AND AND. AND AND.
ENGAGED IN CRIMINAL CONDUCT TO
VIOLATE OF THEY THE USE THAT
INFORMATION SHOULD BE PROSECUTED
IN CHARGE AYE ANYONE THAT'S A
MEMBER OF A UNION ORGANIZATION
THAT USE THAT NUMBER THAT
INFORMATION PROPERLY SHOULD BE.
SUB LET GO AND PROSECUTED IN
CHARGE AND SO THE REALITY IS
THAT THAT THAT IT'S A VERY
NARROW IN TERMS OF WHO GETS
ACCESS. TO THE NAME AND PHONE
NUMBER AS OPPOSED TO PUBLIC
DATABASES IT'S NOT A PUBLIC
DATABASE OF AND IT'S BEEN NEARLY
CRAFTED FOR THAT REASON AND THE
REALITY IS THAT.
PICTURE IT IN MY ESTIMATION
THAT AND OF THESE FROM THE
INFORMATION THAT WE GET IN TERMS
OF BEING CHAIR OF AGING LONG
TERM CARE. THE INFORMATION WE
GET IN TERMS OF THE PLATE OF
HOME CARE AIDES HOMECARE WORKERS
ARE FAR MORE OF THEM THAT ARE
BEING ABUSED HARASSED SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED. BUT DON'T FEEL THEY
HAVE A RECOURSE THAT WOULD AT
LEAST HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE BETTER REPRESENTATION
IF THEY WERE PART OF A UNION AND
SO. THAT THE ISSUES OF THAT YOU
REYES ARE ABSOLUTELY VALID AND
LEGITIMATE AND THAT'S PARTLY WHY
WE'VE NARROWED IT AS MUCH AS WE
HAVE A BUT I ALSO THINK THAT THE
ISSUES OF HARASSMENT AND ABUSE.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY OCCURRING GO
UNCHECKED.
TYPICALLY IF YOU HAVE WORKERS
THE WORKING IN ISOLATION THE
DON'T FEEL THEY'RE PART OF A
SUPPORT NETWORK THAT A LABOR
ORGANIZATION
CAN PROVIDE THEM.
THANK YOU AND THEN THE OTHER
COMMENT.
THAT I WAS VERY IMPORTANT.
FOR US TO TO.
YOU WILL INFORM THE EMPLOYEES OF
THEIR OPT OUT.
PROVISIONS.
BECAUSE THAT'S AGAIN ANOTHER
CONCERN IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA BE GIVEN THE PROPER
INFORMATION EFFORT TALKING
ABOUT.
ALLOWING THEM TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS AND THEN THAT IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT AYE I AGREE
EMPTIVELY SOME OF THAT MAY BE IN
A SENSE SENSE OF SITUATION THAT
MAY BE AN ABUSE SITUATION AND.
WOOD WHEN THEY WAY I'D SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT I WILL BE GREAT TO BE
ABLE TO. CONNECT WITH THE ORGAN
AT LABOR ORGANIZATION TO BE
GRATEFUL TO GET TRAINING BUT
WHEN I WAY THE TWO I'M NOT
WILLING TO RISK PUTTING MY GIVEN
MY NUMBER OF THEM THAT'S THEIR
CHOICE AND WE WOULD NEVER TAKE
THAT AWAY.
THANK YOU AND THEN.
LASTLY I DO HAVE A TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO.
TO ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS AND
I HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS BUT I I
WOULD STILL YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY WAY THAT YOU CAN SIT DOWN
WITH THE WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT BEFORE
PREPARATIONS OR. YOU KNOW EVEN
BEFORE THOUGH IF IT MAKES IT TO
THE FLOOR.
.
AGAIN I'M I HAVE SOME CONCERNS
AGAIN SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
ABUSE OF THE INFORMATION SO IF
YOU CAN ASSURE ME THAT THEN I
WILL I'LL GO AHEAD AND.
OF.
BUT I ARE A BIT MADAM CHARGED OR
WILL ALWAYS REMAIN OPEN.
OBVIOUSLY ON ISSUES LIKE THIS.
THERE THERE MAY BE JUST A
PRINCIPAL DIFFERENCE.
IF THERE'S IF THERE'S JUST AN
INTEREST IN NOT HAVING CLUB UP
THE THE LABOR WORKERS HAVE
ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO INFORM AND
TRAIN AND ORGANIZES WORKERS.
DOCUMENTS PAPERS PRINCIPLE
DIFFERENCE BUT I WILL COMMIT TO
DOING WHATEVER WE CAN TO I THINK
HAS ALREADY BEEN A LOT OF
MOVEMENT MADE. UP TO FROM WHERE
THIS BILL WAS LAST YEAR WHEN
THOSE NAME PHONE NUMBER EMAIL
HALL THAT AT HOME ADDRESS. IT WE
WE THOSE OF THE PRIVACY CONCERN
ISSUES THAT WE DEALT VERY
CLOSELY AND AND AND WITH GREAT
CONCERN OF THE. OF THE CRITIQUE
FROM OPPOSITION SO TO.
JUST MAKE IT CLEAR BE DONE A LOT
IN TERMS OF THE EQUITY TO OF OF
THE OPPOSITION WHETHER WE'RE
GONNA COMPLETELY SATISFY THEM I
CAN'T ASSURE THAT I CAN ASSURE
YOU WILL DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
MAKE. IT AS LONG AS WE KEEP THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE BILL IN PLACE.
THANK YOU WHAT WHAT THAT.
.
SEE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU AND WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THE LOOP THE THANK YOU IS
OF ESCRIBIR. THANK YOU CAN CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
REVIEW AYE REVEAL AYE DUCKS
CHOI.
DUTCH CHOI NO ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
GRASS.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE BISCUITS THREE TWO
ONE AND LIFT ONE. THANK YOU
DEVELOP ITS OWN BECAUSE I THINK
YOU.
YES AND WHILE WE HAVE A QUORUM
CAN WE GO AHEAD AND I DID
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE.
U. LIKE OKAY WHITLOCK YES.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB NINETEEN
THIRTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A I'M I'M
SORRY I ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVEN TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A BETWEEN
NINE OH FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ACOSTA. DO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN A BETWEEN NINE
THIRTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE A. B. THIRTY
NINETY EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RUBIO.
A DEBATE AMONG RUSSIAN.
CAN REVEAL AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI. DARTED CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
DRESSED.%
STONE
STONE AYE THURMOND THURMOND AYE
BUILT INTO CONSENT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE TALKED
WEBER.
GOOD AFTER GOOD AFTERNOON WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR TWENTY THREE
THIRTY ONE GOING ON CONSENT.
THAT BRINGS US TO AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO PAINT WORK IF YOU'RE
TOO HUNGRY BILL.
A. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO IS A BILL TO HELP
PREVENT HUNGER AMONG OUT OF WORK
CALIFORNIANS.
THE CURRENT FEDERAL RULE
ESTABLISHES THAT OUT OF WORK
RECIPIENTS OF CAL FRESH ARE
LIMITED TO THREE MONTHS OF AID
IN ANY THIRTY SIX MONTH PERIOD.
CALIFORNIA HAS A WAIVER TO THIS
RULE BUT EXPIRES AUGUST OF THIS
YEAR.
I REQUEST FOR CONTINUED WAIVER
FROM SOME COUNTIES WILL WITH
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT RATES HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED AND IS CURRENTLY
BEING CONSIDERED BY THE WHITE
HOUSE. BUT A RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND THE NEWLY RELEASED
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM BILL
SUGGEST THAT THE FUTURE OF THESE
AREA. AREA WAIVERS DURING TIMES
OF HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT ARE
UNCLEAR.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THE WORK RATE AMONG CALPERS
RECIPIENTS A HIGH WITH NEARLY
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THOSE ABLE TO
WORK EARNING INCOME TO
IMPLEMENT.
THE CAO FRESH IS THERE TO ALSO
HELP PEOPLE WHO WHEN THEY ARE
OUT OF WORK OR BETWEEN JOBS.
CUTTING PEOPLE OFF FROM A DURING
THIS TIME MAKES IT HARDER FOR
THEM TO FIND A JOB. BUT AB
THIRTY TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO DOES
WILL REQUIRE THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH A HUNGER THRESHOLD.
THAT WILL IDENTIFY WHEN A PERSON
IS TWO HUNDRED TO BE EMPLOYABLE.
THE BILL DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONVENE A WORK GROUP OF
PHYSICIANS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SPECIALIST WILL
EXPERT IN AN ADULT HUNGER. TO
ESTABLISH A THRESHOLD AND BEGIN
AND DESIGN A SCREENING TO USE MY
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS.
ONCE IN PLACE A PERSON WHO
SCREEN IS BEING UNFIT FOR WORK
DUE TO HUNGER WILL BE IF
TEMPORARILY EXEMPT FROM THREE
MONTH TIME LIMIT.
SIMPLY PUT AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO WILL HELP PREVENT OUT OF
WORK CALIFORNIANS FROM GOING
HUNGRY AND BY DOING SO
INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO GET BACK TO
WORK. AB TWO INLAND FIFTY TWO
SPOTS ABOUT THE CUT WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY HERE
TODAY WITH ME TO TEST POSITIVE
JESSICA BOTTLE FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
JESSICA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUST
ABOUT THE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
I'VE SPENT ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
AND AS AN ANTIHUNGER ADVOCATE
AND ADVOCATING FOR THE CALPERS
PROGRAM. AND BUT THAT'S NOT THE
ONLY THING THAT MAKES ME AN
EXPERT ON HUNGER AND ANTI HUNGER
PROGRAMS. I ALSO HAVE BEEN
HUNGRY.
AND I CAN TELL YOU.
PERSONALLY.
THAT HUNGER DOESN'T HELP YOU BE
BETTER AT ANYTHING.
THE FIRST TIME EXPERIENCE
CHRONIC HUNGER. I LOST WEIGHT.
MY CLOTHES DIDN'T FIT.
I WENT FROM BEING THE KID THAT
WAS PICKED SECOND.
BECAUSE I WAS A GIRL WHENEVER
FIRST.
TO THE KID THAT WASN'T PICKED
FOR THE SPORTS.
WAS MY FOURTH GRADE YEAR.
AND MY DAD COULDN'T FIND WORK
WHO'S A CONSTRUCTION WORKER.
AND ON IT WAS A SNOWY WINTER AND
LAKE TAHOE.
THAT YEAR BECAUSE I WAS IN
FOURTH GRADE I WAS A TESTED FOR
GATE.
AND I WAS PLACED IN THE GATE
CLASS.
AND THEN I WAS REMOVED FROM THE
BACK GATE CLASS
BECAUSE I COULDN'T KEEP UP. I
COULDN'T STAY AWAKE IN CLASS.
THESE ARE THE EXPERIENCES OF
PEOPLE CHILDREN ADULTS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE VETERANS PEOPLE
WHO ARE OLDER.
WHO WILL EXPERIENCE HUNGER AS A
RESULT OF THE PROPOSED CUTS IN
DC? WHO ARE EXPERIENCING HUNGER
TODAY BECAUSE?
ONLY ABOUT SEVENTY PERCENT OF
PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR
PARTICIPATING.
AND THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHOM I
WILL HOPEFULLY BENEFIT FROM. AND
THEIR PARENTS OR THEY THEMSELVES
HAVING A SCREENING. THE HELPS
IDENTIFY WHEN THEY'RE HAVING.
THE EXPERIENCE OF CHRONIC
HUNGER.
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE A
TEMPORARY RELIEF FROM THE
MANDATORY WORK REQUIREMENTS IN
THE PROGRAM.
WHEN THE BILL WAS INTRODUCED WE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS GOING TO BE INTRODUCING AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER MAKING THE WORK
REQUIREMENTS HARDER. AND WE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT A. THE HOUSE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE WOULD BE
PASSING A A FARM BILL ON A
PARTISAN BASIS WHICH.
I'M NOT ONLY SHORTENS THE TIME
LIMIT FROM THREE MONTHS TO ONE
MONTH FOR OUT OF WORK AMERICANS
BUT ALSO APPLY TO TO FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN.
SO WE'RE SO GRATEFUL AND FOR THE
FAMILY LEGISLATION AND.
WE URGE YOUR AT YOUR VOTE YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR THE BILL.
FROM WESTERN CENTER AND FOR ME
PERSONALLY ON BEHALF OF HUNGRY
AMERICANS APPRECIATE YOUR IBOOK
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANGELA WILLIAMS CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH THAT WORK IN SUPPORT.
LAURIE FURSTENFELD FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAW CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN AS THEIR QUARTERS
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CASEY MEN AND.
ANYONE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I I HAVE A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR ARE AYE HOUSE SUPPORT
TERM. YOUR. BILL IN CONCEPT THE.
BUT THE HOLLOW WHICH YOU.
ENSURE A DATA CABLE OR BODY
OWNERS TRY.
TO LOOK FOR A JOB BUT AND
INTENTIONALLY TRY TO AVOID.
EGGMAN EMPLOYMENT TOOK WHEN.
YOU MAKE IT EASIER.
ARE WHY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IS A TRACK TO TIGHTEN UP THAT
THE RESOURCES SUCH AS AVAILABLE
MIGHT FEDERAL BLOOM.
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE IS A TRULY
HUNGRY PEOPLE URGE A SHOULD BE
HELPED UP BUT THE.
NOW.
AS.
.
YOUR FREE MONEY IT IS AVAILABLE
AND CONTINUOUSLY AND. A REPEAT
THIS ARE INCENTIVIZE OF THE
WUSA.
OF WHO DON'T WANT TO WORK AND US
SICK FOR EMPLOYMENT.
JOINT WAS FUN TO EXPAND THOSE
WHO REALLY MATTER.
BETTER.
I AM.
S. ARIAS IT MAKES ME A LITTLE
EMOTIONAL BONTA TO HEAR THE
QUESTION.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
.
THERE'S A GREAT ASSUMPTION THAT
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PROGRAMS.
IF THEIR THEIR.
AND THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS.
THAT NOBODY GROWS UP THINKING
HEY I WANT TO BE ON FOOD STAMPS.
.
THERE ARE PEOPLE. UP WHO THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO CHEAT THE
SYSTEM. OF WE HAVE ONE OF THE
BEST
ANTI FRAUD OF PROGRAMS IN SNAP
IT'S IT HAS ONE OF THE LOWEST
ERROR RATES. THAN ANY GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY.
ON. AND.
AND EVEN IF THERE ARE A HANDFUL
OF PEOPLE THAT WILL CHEAT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO PUNISH
EVERYBODY ELSE BECAUSE THEY DO
IT'S CRUEL. TO LET SOMEBODY GO
WITHOUT FOOD.
ON AND THAT WE DO THAT IN A
STATE AS WEALTHY AND.
AS GREAT AS WE ARE.
MAKES NO SENSE ON.
THIS BILL I WILL REQUIRE PEOPLE
TO CERTIFY. THAT THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED HUNGER.
A AT THE RATE THAT WOULD QUALIFY
THEM FOR THE EXEMPTION SO SELF
CERTIFICATION WOULD BE REQUIRED
UNLIKELY THOUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF WOULD BE UP TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
AND DOWN.
I PERSONALLY HAVE GREAT FAITH IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATORS OF FOR THE WORK
THAT THEY DO TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM.
WORKING THE WAY IT SHOULD
BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO ARE LOW
INCOME AND.
WHO RELY ON THE PROGRAM? WANT TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE DON'T CHEAT TO
THEM THERE'S NO NOBODY.
WHO HATES A WELFARE TO? BUY
MORE THAN A WELFARE RECIPIENT.
AND THAT'S THAT IS THE TRUTH
SO ON. WE WOULD WE WOULD TRUST
THAT THAT THE COUNTY AND THE
STATE ADMINISTRATORS WOULD.
IMPLEMENT THOUGH THE LIES ARE
REQUIRED TO IN WAYS THAT WOULD
PREVENT FRAUD.
CANNABIS IT WILL LOOK AS A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION.
WITH A SORCERER DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES ARE IF I ASK FOR
OF.
OF FREE FOOD AND THE UC MIA I'M
A POOR BODY AND I SHOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK A AND THEN. CAN YOU
OFFER ME A JOB IF I THEY'VE
REFUSE IT THAT WOULD I BE
DISQUALIFIED.
THERE ARE A THERE'S THEIR
CURRENT OF REGULATIONS AND THAT
WOULD REQUIRE YOU TO LOOK FOR
WORK AND REGISTER FOR WORK THIS
WOULDN'T. EAT IT NOTHING ABOUT
THIS A BILL WOULD RELIEVE PEOPLE
OF THEIR REQUIREMENT TO REGISTER
FOR WORK.
AND THERE ARE OTHER POLICIES IN
THE FOOD STAMP PROGRAM AND THAT
WOULD SAY FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE
IF YOU ARE OFFERED A JOB. AND
YOU REFUSE IT.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT A DIFFERENT
PART OF THE LAW AND YOU WOULD BE
DENIED BENEFITS FOR A PERIOD OF
THREE MONTHS. IF YOU HAVE A JOB
AND YOU.
IT IF YOU HAVE A JOB AND YOU
QUIT THE JOB VOLUNTARILY. YOU'RE
ALSO DISQUALIFIED FOR A PERIOD
OF THREE MONTHS OR IF YOU APPLY
FOR BENEFITS AFTER HAVING
VOLUNTARILY QUIT A JOB.
YOU'RE INELIGIBLE THIS BILL
WOULDN'T CHANGE ANY PART OF
THAT.
YOU'RE ALSO NOT ALLOWED TO
REDUCE YOUR HOURS BELOW TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AT OR ELSE
YOU WOULD BECOMING ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM EITHER AS AN
APPLICANT OR RECIPIENT AND
THAT'S ALSO CURRENT LAW. AMANITA
PLACE TO FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN
OR FAMILIES WITHOUT CHILDREN.
SO. IN YOUR EXAMPLE.
IF YOU TURN DOWN A JOB. AND.
A OR IF YOU QUIT A JOB OR IF YOU
REDUCE YOUR HOURS BELOW A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD YOU WOULD BE
DENIED AID AND NOTHING ABOUT
THIS THIS BILL WOULD. PREVENT
THAT.
THANK.
THINKING JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
ACCEPTING THEM AND CHIPS
THANK YOU OUT WITH THAT WHICH IS
LIKE CLOTHES SURE OF I'VE I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND.
AS POINTED OUT YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S COOL TO BE IN THE STATE'S
WEALTHIEST CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE HUNGRY.
SO HUNGRY THAT THEY CAN'T
FUNCTION THAT THEY CAN'T THINK
WE SEE THAT IN OUR SCHOOLS EVERY
DAY.
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE HOMELESS IN
WHO WERE HUNGRY AND WHEN THE
WEALTHY STATE IN THE WORLD. I
NEVER WANT TO EVER DIDN'T I
HELPING SOMEONE BECAUSE SOMEONE
ELSE WHO DOESN'T NEED HELP MIGHT
BENEFIT FROM IT.
YOU KNOW THE BY WILL ALWAYS
TELLS AT THE SUN SHINES ON THE
JUST AND THE UNJUST AT THE SAME
TIME. UP AND THERE'S ALWAYS
CONSEQUENCES OF EVERYTHING FOR
THOSE WHO DECIDE TO CHEAT BUT WE
ABOVE THE LOTS OF EFFORTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO AVOID
THOSE WHO COMMIT FRAUD WHO
CHEAT.
AND YOU STILL HAVE SOME WHO DO
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO CHEAT ON THEIR
TAXES WOULD NOT EVEN OF
GOVERNMENT RECIPIENTS AT ALL.
BUT SIMPLY BUT DO THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHO THEY ARE AND SO I
WOULD I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD
FOCUS ON. WHAT THE REAL ISSUE IS
AT HAND IS THAT THAT WE HAVE A
LOT OF FOLKS WILL HUNGRY? O.
SOMETIMES AS A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
WE TRY TO PUT A LOT OF
STIPULATIONS ON THINGS THAT MAKE
IT SO COMPLICATED. THAT WE
ALMOST BENEFIT NO ONE. AND.
I'VE TOLD SOME STUDENTS
RECENTLY BECAUSE OF ALL THE
HUNGER BILLS WE DONNA CAMPUSES.
THAT WAS KIND OF GLAD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DID NOT TAKE UP THE
ISSUE OF REGULATING THEIR FOOD
BANKS AND THEIR THEIR PANTRIES
IN THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
BECAUSE OF SO THAT PROBABLY NO
ONE WOULD EVER GET FOOD. OF BUT
THE STUDENTS HAVE THE KIND OF
HEART THAT NOBODY WANTS TO
REALLY ASK FOR FOOD NO ONE WANTS
TO BE AN ASSISTANCE. THEY ALL
HELP OUT AND WHEN SOMEONE SAYS
I'M HUNGRY THEY COME TO BELIEVE
THEM WE'RE GONNA DEVELOP A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM THOUGH THAT
WOULD HAVE A OF METRICS IN WHICH
THEY COULD LOOK AT. THE ISSUE OF
HUNGER IN A PERSON'S LIFE AND
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAS BECOME
AN IMPEDIMENT TO IT BUT I THINK
IT'S A STATE AS GREAT AS THIS
NATION.
IF YOU PASS BY SOMEONE WHO'S
HUNGRY AND YOU DON'T FEEL THE
SENSE OF PAIN YOURSELF AND
SOMETHING IS REALLY WRONG WITH
YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU
AYE VOTE FOR AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
TWO.
I AM DOCTOR WEBER AND I JUST
WANNA CLARIFY THINK I HEARD IT A
COUPLE TIMES THAT IT IN THE
STATE AS WHAT THE OZAWA. IS THAT
AS WE ARE THAT IT'S COOL IT'S
JUST CRUEL NO MATTER WHAT STATE
WHEREIN. I AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
THAT POINT BECAUSE IT'S COOL
JUST FOR KIDS TO BE HUNGRY I WAS
A TEACHER FOR
SENIORS AND. I HAD.
TO TEACH KIDS THAT DIDN'T HAVE
FOOD.
WE'RE EXPECTING THEM TO LEARN.
TO READ IN THAT REGARD READ
WRITE AN ARITHMETIC RIGHT AND
AND WILL THEY DON'T HAVE PROPER
PROPER MEALS AND.
SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S NOT JUST COHEN THE
STATE LIKE OURS IT'S JUST CRUEL
CREATED PERIOD AND SO WITH THAT.
I DO HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
DO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS IF YOU CAN CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO.
REPEAL AYE DR CHOI. THOUGHT TO
CHOI AYE AT NUMBER LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND. THURMOND AYE
BUILDERS OUT BEFORE THE STATE
OF.
THANK YOU I AM I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY OUR TO CLARIFY THE
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR A. B. TWENTY NINE THIRTY
THREE MEDINA. I WAS READING
CORRECTLY IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN DO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS NOT TO PASS
AS AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
A. PHASER ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
HERE NOW
CAME MAIENSCHEIN FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON IS HERE. I KNOW WAS GIVEN
TO YOU MISTER GIBSON PLEASE COME
ON UP.
AND WE LEFT. IT'S ITEM.
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. LIKE TO START BY.
SAYING I ACCEPT THE MINUTES OF
THOSE OFFERED BY THIS COMMITTEE
THIS COMMITTEE. WHICH ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR. OF THE STAFF
WORKING SO CLOSE WITH US TO HELP
IMPROVE HIS BILL TO MAKE IT
BETTER. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX OH FIVE
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT GROUP
HOMES AND FOSTER CARE FACILITIES
HAVE PROTOCOLS THAT STRICT CALLS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT ON FOSTER
YOU.
AS A LAST RESORT MANY GROUP CARE
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO RELY ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AS A PRIMARY
BEHAVIOR MANAGEMENT RESPONSE TO
MINOR INCIDENTS THAT I ONE
UNDERSCORE MINOR INCIDENTS
FOSTER YOU. HAVE BEEN ARRESTED.
FOR.
FOOD FIGHTS WITH CAKE ICING AND
CHARGED WITH INCITING A RIOT.
AND IN OTHER INSTANCES ON
CHILDREN WHO POKE.
AT A CARE GIVER WITH A CANDY
CANE WAS ARRESTED FOR ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING
CRIMINALIZE
FOR BEHAVIOR THAT CAN BE
EXPECTED FROM ANY CHILD THAT'S
GROWING UP. AND I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE WE WOULD NOT CALL THE
POLICE ON OUR BIOLOGICAL CHILD.
FOR.
DISAGREEMENT FOR A POKING WITH
A CANDY CANE OR A FOOD FIGHT
WITH A CAKE OR NOT GOING TO
SLEEP OR NOT EATING OUR FOOD. SO
WHY SHOULD WE CALL THE POLICE TO
HANDLE A FOSTER YOU THAT YOU
ACCEPT INTO YOUR HOME THAT YOU
PLEDGE TO PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE
IN THE LEADERSHIP. ON TO THAT
CHILD SO THAT TALKING GROW UP TO
BE A RESPECTED.
CITIZEN ACCORDING TO THE
PARTNER OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OF THESE
CALLS RESULT IT RESULTED IN FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE YOUTH
BEING SIDE IT. FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN YOUTH BEING
DETAINED OR ARRESTED AND ENOUGH
AND ANOTHER ON THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN BEING BOOKED INTO
JUVENILE HALL. THESE FACILITIES
ARE LICENSE AND COMPENSATED TO
MANAGE THE BEHAVIOR THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS BEING
INAPPROPRIATELY RELIED UPON AND
TO HANDLE. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX OH FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
FOSTER I CARE FACILITIES TO
DEVELOP A PROTOCOL THAT
SPECIFIES WIN IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO CALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THESE PROTOCOLS
MUST SPECIFY THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WILL ONLY BE CONTACTED AS A LAST
RESORT WITH A APPROVAL OF A
SUPERVISORS.
OF THESE MAYOR MIRRORS POLICIES
OF OTHER FACILITIES THAT ARE
ALREADY BEING UP IMPLEMENTED
ARMITAGE JOB WELL DONE WITH
THOSE ON TO THOSE PARTICULAR
FACILITIES. UP THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES STAFF TO UNDERGO AN
ANNUAL TRAINING ON PROTOCOLS THE
PROTOCOLS MUST ALSO ADDRESS
CONTACTING LAW ENFORCEMENT IN IN
CASE OF EMERGENCY SITUATION. IF
THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE RISK.
ANYONE AND THE FACILITY OF
FOSTER YOU HAVE FACED
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA AND THEIR
LIFE. A LIFETIME AND AND DESERVE
A BETTER THAN BEING SENT TO
JUVENILE HALL AS A WAY OF TIME
OUT HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES ARE
REPRESENTATIVES. FROM THE YOU
THE LAW CENTER AS WELL AS THE
THE FATHER AND FAMILY OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
NO.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MARIA RENEW.
A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
YOUTH LAW CENTER. AYE WE'RE
PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
SIX OH FIVE.
WITH FATHERS AND FAMILIES OF
SAN JOAQUIN POLICY LINK AND
COMMUNITIES UNITED FROM START
OF.
YOUTH JUSTICE
OUGHT TO REDUCE
THE. OF RELIANCE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN FOSTER CARE
FACILITIES.
AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE BUILDS ON.
PRIOR LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS AYE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT.
REQUIRED GROUP FACILITIES TO
REPORT THEIR CONTACTS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. PA REQUIRED THAT
THOSE OF REPORTS BI ANNUALLY
AVAILABLE.
ONLINE. IT REQUIRED INCREASED
OVERSIGHT BY BE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IT DIDN'T
DO WAS TO PROVIDE US SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE TO FACILITIES. OR TO
THE OVERSIGHT AGENCY ON HOW TO
REDUCE THOSE CALLS
I AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE BUILDS
ON WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM. US
SOME OF THE THAT THE DATA THAT'S
BEEN REPORTED.
MAJORITY OF THE CALLS THAT ARE
MADE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE FOR
NON AGGRESSIVE TO. NON
ASSAULTIVE BEHAVIOR AYE AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT.
AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE DOZEN
ESTABLISHING STANDARDS FOR
FACILITIES AND FOR CDSS IN
OVERSEEING THESE FACILITIES.
THIS PROVIDE CORE ELEMENTS THAT
FACILITY SHOULD HAVE IN THEIR
POLICIES ABOUT WHEN TO CALL THE
POLICE
WE THINK THAT THIS WHAT IS A
NEEDED IMPROVEMENT.
THAT WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THE REDUCTION OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN IN FOSTER CARE
FACILITIES. AND WILL ELIMINATE
SOME OF THE A BUT LEMONADE THE
TRIVIAL USE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO MANAGE BASIC BEHAVIOR THAT A
ANY CHILD OR ADOLESCENT MAY
ENGAGE IN.
I'M GOING TO HAND THIS OVER TO
SHED.
THANK YOU.
GREETINGS CHAIRMAN AND CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME WITH
COUNTY HOLLOW MAN I WAS THE
VULNERABLE YOU THAT WAS ARRESTED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGE THIRTEEN
FOR DISTURBING THE PEACE.
I WITH NOT ONLY FOR THEM I THINK
IF YOU ARE BILL LIKE I WAS BEING
PUNISHED. THIS SHELTER SHELTER
THEME TO JUVENILE HALL INSTEAD
OF COUNSELING WHICH I GREATLY
NEED IT TO DO WITH MY TIME.
I KNOW OTHER QUALIFY FOR FOSTER
HOME. SO THAT TOOK AWAY THE
CHANCE FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO BE
PLACED WITH THE NORMAL FAMILY.
WHICH WAS PUNISHMENT ENOUGH AT
THAT TIME I FELT LIKE I NEEDED
TO BE TOLD THINGS WERE GOING TO
BE OKAY. MY BEHAVIOR COULD EING
HERE WITH JUST SOMETHING AS A
SIMPLE HUG IN FOR ME.
THIS THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN GREAT.
GOODNESS.
ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
HI ANNA JOHNSON WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FEES FAHNESTOCK
SUPPORT.
LIZZIE BEACON WITH THE ACLU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
EVELYN AB HUSON DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS PARK.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BROUGHT SOME BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DOCTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
THE BEAT ADDRESS CITY WITH ALL
OF US ARE NONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LAURIE FURSTENFELD IN STRONG
SUPPORTER AS A FORMER SOCIAL
WORKER WHO WORKED IN A LEVEL
FOURTEEN GRUPOM WHO HAD TO CALL
THE POLICE ON LITTLE KIDS FOR
MINOR INCIDENTS I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT GIVE.
STEPHANIE I'VE LEARNED
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT I'D
LIKE TO GO ON RECORD HOWEVER IN
SAYING. THAT ARE NINETY
NATIONALLY ABOUT ITEM NO WORSE
WE'RE JUST TAKING SUPPORT WERE
NOT ABLE TO TAKE MORE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ENGAGING US.
KIANA PATTERSON WITH HOP SKIP
DRIVE IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA DABNEY WITH THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IF YOU ANYWHERE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SING NONE.
BUT.
ANOTHER SHOT POSITIONING MORE
JONATHON FELDMAN CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION I WE
WERE OPPOSE THE ORIGINAL VERSION
OF THE BILL WHICH STATUTORY
RESTRICTED THE SOUNDS IN CALLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT WE THINK
THAT THE AMENDMENTS TO MOVE IT
TO MORE OF POLICY IN.
INTERNAL.
CONTROLS WITHIN THAT.
FACILITIES IS MUCH MORE
APPROPRIATE WE THINK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF AND THE SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND WITH THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
RIGHT SIGNIN.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE BUT.
NOT MUCH HERE.
YEAH I WILL SO THERE'S NOT.
NINETEEN SOMEBODY HERE TO MAKE
A MOTION WILL HAVE TO TAKE UP
MOTIONS AND ALL THAT ONCE WE
GET.
ENOUGH FOLKS BACK SO PLEASE BEAR
WITH US SKIPS AND YOU MAKE
CLOTHES SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OR THANK OUR SPONSORS ALSO THE
WITNESS BUT ON AN IMPECCABLE
JOB.
THIS BILL I CERTAINLY REP I SORT
OF BELIEVE REPRESENT HOPE IT
REPRESENTS SUCH A NEW CHAPTER
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WHO THE MOST VULNERABLE WHO ARE
FOSTER YOU COULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO GET THAT HUG
NAM.
THAT A HUG WILL GO A LONG WAY IN
TERMS OF DEFUSING A LOT OF
SITUATIONS SPECIAL WE TALK
ABOUT.
IMPRESSIONABLE CHILDREN WHO
ALREADY HAS FACED A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TRAUMA JUST BY BEING
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
ITSELF.
AND SO MY HEART GOES OUT TO.
FOSTERED BY YOU I MEAN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT OUR JOB IS TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE IT
BETTER I BELIEVE THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND
CERTAINLY RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE
I VOTE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL CERTAINLY TAKE IT UP
THEN. PRIDE MISTER CORP ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. TWENTY ONE
ELEVEN.
NUMBER
.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
I BET YOU KNOW ALL ABOUT THIS.
.
AND I DON'T HAVE MUCH VOICE SO
JUST LET ME SAY THAT I'M GOING
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
AND TO STRENGTHEN THE BILL BY
REQUIRING COUNTIES TO RENEW CAL
WORKS INTO CHECK SECTIONS. AND
THEN I WILL PASS THIS ON TO MY.
WITNESSES
OUR THANK YOU YOUR FIRST
WITNESS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SUNNY SAT BY
SO CALLED THE FBI. I'M THE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT ALAMEDA
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES AGENCY.
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS HONORED TO BE
WORKING CLOSELY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK.
AND THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY TO CO SPONSOR
ASSEMBLY BELL TWENTY ONE ELEVEN.
CURRENTLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A COUNTY CAN MAKE A
DETERMINATION THAT HE SPONSORED
NON CITIZEN WOULD GO HUNGRY. AND
HOMELESS WITHOUT AID.
AND DETERMINE HIM OR HER TO BE
INDIGENT.
FOR YOUR REFERENCE CAL FRESH AND
CAL WORKS INDIGENTS
DETERMINATIONS ARE ONLY VALID
FOR TWELVE MONTH PERIOD.
IN THE CAL FRESH PROGRAM.
THESE DETERMINATIONS ARE
RENEWABLE ANNUALLY WITHOUT
RESTRICTION.
HOWEVER IN CAL WORKS
THERE IS NO PROVISION FOR
RENEWAL.
AND AN INDIGENT EXCEPTION MAY
ONLY BE GRANTED ONCE AND ON A
SPONSORED NON CITIZENS LIKE
TIME.
REMOVING UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO
SUPPORT INDIGENT IMMIGRANTS
IT'S CRITICAL. ESPECIALLY NOW
DURING A TIME OF FEDERAL
UNCERTAINTY.
FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY THIS WOULD
MEAN ASSISTING LASSEN FORTY
INDIVIDUALS A YEAR TO RECEIVE
THIS BENEFIT.
WELL SMALL IN NUMBER IT WOULD
HELP OUR COMMUNITY TREMENDOUSLY.
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I'D LIKE TO
READ INTO THE RECORD TESTIMONY
FROM AN ALAMEDA COUNTY CLIENT
WHO WAS HESITANT TO COME FORWARD
OUT OF FEAR OF THE GOVERNMENT
BUT WANTED TO SHARE HIS STORY.
MY NAME IS MISTER PRESCOTT.
I RIDE TO THE UNITED STATES FROM
TONGA WITH MY WIFE AND CHILD. AS
SPONSORED NON CITIZENS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
I WAS GAINFULLY EMPLOYED UNTIL
ONE TRAGIC MORNING IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN GETTING
READY FOR WORK I SUFFERED A
STROKE.
HAVING LIMITED RESOURCES AND NO
CONTACT WITH MY SPONSOR.
I APPLIED FOR CAL WORKS.
THE AID REALLY HELPED ME WHEN WE
HAD NO OTHER INCOME.
BUT THAT CASH WAS CUT OFF AFTER
ONE YEAR AND WE SUFFERED.
WE COULD NO LONGER PAY OUR RENT
OR ARE BILLS.
I HAD TO FIND ANOTHER SOURCE OF
INCOME. EVEN THOUGH I WAS STILL
RECUPERATING FROM A STROKE.
FINDING EMPLOYMENT WITH A
CHALLENGE AS MY PHYSICAL
ABILITIES WERE LIMITED. AND IT
WAS HEARTBREAKING TO SEE MY
CHILD AND WIFE SUFFER.
TODAY I AM LUCKY TO HAVE A JOB
BUT IF I LOSE MY JOB.
I AM ONLY ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
LOSING MY HOME.
LAWS LIKE AB TWENTY ONE ELEVEN
WILL HELP US PROVIDE THE BASIC
NECESSITIES FOR OUR FAMILIES.
PLEASE HELP PASS THIS BILL SO
THAT OUR CHILDREN CAN HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IN CLOSING.
NO HUMAN SHOULD HAVE TO FACE THE
POSSIBILITY OF GOING HOMELESS OR
HUNGRY INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS.
PLEASE HELP PROTECT THE
PRESCOTT'S OF OUR STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORT IN ADVANCE.
THANK YOU AND MR QUIRK THERE THE
PREVIOUS NIGHT ASKING FOR AMEND
SO I NEED TO TAKE A MEMBERS
THERE'S NOT AMENDMENTS HERE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
JUST TO CLARIFY.
ALRIGHT WELL.
AT SOME POINT I WAS ASKED TO
MAYBE THEY'VE BEEN TAKEN ALREADY
TO MAKE IT MAY TO SHALL AND I'M
CHANGING THE MAID WHO SHALL
WHETHER IT'S.
HERE ARE APPROPRIATIONS ARE I'VE
TAKEN THAT ALREADY.
BUT ABSOLUTELY GET DOZEN MEMBERS
OF EARLY VOTING ACROSS SO NOW
CAN IT SO SORRY IN THE BILL GOOD
YET.
ALRIGHT SO. NEXT WITNESS THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION TO THIS SO YOU CAN
BE BRIEF THANK YOU AND MISTER
SHARON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO ASK ABOUT THE WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WERE APPRENTICED
COSPONSORED THE SPELL I JUST
WANNA. UP POINT OUT THAT THE
OPTION TO MAKE THESE CONSECUTIVE
TWELVE MONTHS HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE.
SINCE THE BALANCED BUDGET ACT
OF NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND
FURTHER CLARIFICATION WAS
PROVIDED UNDER THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE A WHICH I
PROVIDED THAT WE COULD THAT AT
AT THE STATE'S OPTION AND MAKE
THIS A CONSECUTIVE AND
CONTINUOUS TWELVE MONTHS.
AND OF THE AS ADVOCATES WE'VE
BEEN ASKING AT THE STATE AND
COUNTIES TO DO THIS FOR SOMETIME
WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATION THINGS IT'S GREATLY
NEEDED.
AND PROUD TO REQUEST YOUR I
BUILT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF THAT
COALITION CALIFORNIA WHAT THE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES THIS POINT BRING THE
PROCESS JUST LIKE CAL WORKS OF
WITH TOWERS PROGRAM. EVERY
TWELVE MONTHS TO RECERTIFY.
BENHAMOU UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THEY CUT YOU OFF THAT YOU
HAVE TO WE APPLIED THAT THE
BECOME HOMELESS THAT YOU CAN'T
FIND A PLACE. DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
SO JUST REMIND THE SYSTEM IS
SIMPLIFIED THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU AND YOUR BREAKING THE
CHAIR'S RULES ABOUT TWO
WITNESSES SO. EVERYONE ELSE WILL
JUST TAKE.
THAT YEAR GIVE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND THEY SUPPORT
THE FELT THANK YOU THAT
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
KAREN LAYING ON HIM BEHALF OF
MAYOR MARK FARRELL. THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
FINE FOLKS WORKING IN THEIR
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT AUSTIN
FREE EITHER TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KELLY BUCKS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF THE
I'M COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
LAURIE FURSTENFELD FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAW CENTER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYWHERE ELSE IN
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF RARE BACK TO AN
EMPTY COMMITTEE WILL TAKE A
MOTION.
BUT WE GET FOLKS BACK THANK YOU
I THINK.
FRASER YOU HAVE A COUPLE ITEMS
WITH US TODAY.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND I HAVE SOME WITNESSES THAT
ARE.
.
CUT A SENSITIVE TO TIME FOR. OF
THEM. IF WE COULD CHANGE IT TO
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR FIRST.
SURE PLEASE.
FINE BY ME THEY HAVE LEFT ME
HERE ON MY OWN SO.
YOU GET TO DECIDE WHAT THEY AND
I SAY SO ITEM TWENTY AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
AND ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR EMPOWERS
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THROUGH AN
INTEGRATED COMPETITIVE
EMPLOYMENT.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW FOR ON THE
JOB SKILLS TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH COMMUNITY
BASED VOCATIONAL SERVICES.
YOU HEARD THIS BILL LAST YEAR
AND IT'S BACK BECAUSE IT'S
IMPERATIVE WE EXPAND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO INDIVIDUALS.
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I'M ADDRESSING THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO MESSAGE BY WORKING WITH THE
DDS THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
BUDGET.
A LONG TERM INVESTMENT IMPLEMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH AIDID DE
BRINGS IN A RETURN TO CALIFORNIA
BY ALLOWING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY TO BECOME SELF
RELIANT.
AND LESS DEPENDENT ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
I HOPE YOU CAN JOIN ME IN
SUPPORT OF A COMMUNITY THAT IS
DEAR TO MY HEART.
WITH ME TODAY IS VERY JOURNEY
WOULD CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY
SERVICES AND MY GOOD FRIEND
AUDRA.
A SITE SOME TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
VERY.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIR OTHER
GETTING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR AS A FAMILY MEMBER
SAID WITH HER SECOND GO ROUND AT
THIS. AND WHEN I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL.
AS WELL AS BEING A CHAMPION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AYE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT FIRST
POLICIES THAT.
PRIORITIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
REGARDLESS OF THE SEVERITY OF
THEIR DISABILITIES. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY STILL OF
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES APPROACHING
THE NINETY PERCENT MARK FOR FOR
THAT PART FOR THIS POPULATION.
AND WHAT WE SEE IS THAT OF
MISSING LINK IS EMPLOYMENT
EXPLORATION AND JOB DISCOVERY IN
SOME THE PRE VOCATIONAL SERVICES
THAT ARE REQUIRED. OR BITTER
COULD FACILITATE THAT
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATE
EMPLOYMENT.
AND SO AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
REALLY HAS A TWO TWO MAIN GOALS.
IN IN TWO WAYS TO ADDRESS THAT
THAT GAP IMPROVE OCCASIONAL
SERVICES.
THE FIRST IS TO ADDRESS THE.
COMMUNITY BASED VOCATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY CHAPTER IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THROUGH S. B.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN. UNFORTUNATE
THAT BILL WAS NEVER IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE IT REQUIRED FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION AND WE.
WHERE INFORMED BY DDS THAT
WOULD IT WOULD NEED A STANDALONE
WAIVER WITH CMS IN ORDER TO GO
INTO EFFECT?
WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE IS THAT
REMOVE THE PILOT LANGUAGE FROM
THE BILL SO THAT THE THE
COMMUNITY BASED FOCUS ON
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES COULD BE
WRAPPED INTO THE EXISTING H. CBS
WAIVER? AND THEREFORE WOULD NOT
REQUIRE ANY YOU KNOW NEW WAVER
WITH CMS AT THE SECOND AIM IS TO
WORK ON FOLKS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
EMPLOYMENT GROUPS OR WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAM STATE PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM. TO
TRANSITION INTO MORE COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATE EMPLOYMENT IF THAT'S
THEIR CHOICE SO THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO USE TAYLOR DAY SERVICES
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR
EXISTING SERVICES TO FACILITATE
ON THOSE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AND OUTCOMES.
WITH ME TODAY IS UNDER SUCH
THEM AND I ONE OF JUST GIVE HER
THE FLOOR FOR THE REST THE TIME
TO. SPEAK TO HER EXPERIENCE AND
WHAT SHE WOULD. LIKE TO SEE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MISSOURI.
I HAVE A.
.
JOB AND AND AND HOW DOES ME.
MOVIE AND THE OTHER DO
DIFFERENTLY. PAVE IF BURKE TO
AND I I LOVE IT AYE. AYE MOON
CHANGE.
ANYTHING ABOUT IT I WOULD DO IS
VERY OF THAT.
.
CABLE.
AND.
MED THAT.
YEAH.
EVER.
SUMS IT UP CRICHTON.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR RUBIO AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LISA COOLEY
I'M A FORMER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. SENATOR FRASER'S BUILD
IT WILL GIVE MORE PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK.
AND COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT WITH.
DECENT WAGES AND BENEFITS THANK
YOU.
IT IS PROMOTED.
HE PROVIDED THEM TO SENATOR.
THANK YOU.
EVELYN I'M PLUS DISABILITY
RIGHTS CONFERENCE PARK.
SIDNEY JACKSON ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
ARCHIVES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH ARKIN UCP
CALIFORNIA CONGRESSMAN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JEALOUS A SERVICE MEMBER ON
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THE STATE COUNCILS IN SUPPORT
THINKING YOU.
THIS IS MY OTHER STALKER.
WHO WHO WHO? WHO?
LOCAL BUS LOG FUTURES EXPLORED
ALIVE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU
.
A CARL LONDON ON BEHALF OF THE
LINES.
INDIVIDUALS
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES AND SPORTS WELL
THANK YOU.
JASON PARKS WITH FEATURES
EXPLORED.
SUPPORTIVE EMPLOYMENT TAYLOR
DAYS SERVICE AND DEFINITE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KILL. THEM BUT RIGHT.
THANK YOU I WOULD THAT I DO NEED
A MOTION.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND I BRING IT ME.
BRINGING BACK UP TO THE DIET
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
KATE. I'M HEARING THEN ALONG I
HAVE AND MOTION TO.
ITS HAD TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE CLOSE
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR THIS WONDERFUL
POPULATION OF PEOPLE.
THANK YOU WHAT THAT CAN YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE RUBIO AYE AYE
REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE AND I'M LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
OKAY YES. STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE VILLAGE OUT FOR
THIS YEAR VILLAGE OUT FOUR ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VENTURE THANK YOU AND THEN WE
HAVE A YOUR NEXT I DON'T.
YES MA'AM.
MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON THOSE.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE
FOCUSES ON THE INDIVIDUAL AND
THEIR GOALS.
INSURERS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES ARE COORDINATING
EFFECTIVELY TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THROUGH THE INITIAL PHASES OF
THE INTERVAL INDIVIDUALIZED
PLANNING PROCESS.
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE DR BOLIVIA RAINER AND
JANELLE LUIS A PARENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY FOR AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE SYSOP.
I'M BOLIVIA RAINER I DIRECT THE
TORSION CENTER AT UCLA WE ARE
UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR EXCELLENCE
IN DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
OUR CENTER HAS BEEN WORKING IN
THE AREA OF TRANSITION TO AND.
TO EMPLOYMENT FOR DECADES.
AND DOES THE WE USE ARE THE
RESEARCH THAT WE CONDUCT AND OUR
WORK.
TO SUPPORT THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
I AM ALSO IS A MEMBER OF THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. THE FIFTEEN
PERCENT EMPLOYMENT RATE OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE
ADDRESSES FUNDAMENTAL UP
PROBLEMS PEOPLE EXPERIENCE IN
ACHIEVING COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT.
SPECIFICALLY THESE PROBLEMS
INCLUDE A TRANSITION CLIFF
WHEREBY STUDENTS LEAVE HIGH
SCHOOL WITHOUT A COORDINATED
PLAN FOR THEIR FUTURE. THAT
RESULTS IN MANY TRANSITIONING
FROM SCHOOL. TO NOTHING OR WORSE
YET TO THE FAMILY'S COUCH.
A LACK OF THE CENTRAL
COMMUNICATION ACROSS AGENCIES IN
THE PLANNING AND DELIVERY OF
SERVICES AND A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS AGENCIES
FOR SUCCESSFUL ACHIEVEMENT OF
EMPLOYMENT.
AB TWENTY ONE A SEVENTY ONE
STRENGTHENS THE CALIFORNIA
BLUEPRINT FOR EMPLOYMENTS
EFFORTS
BY IMPLEMENTING SPECIFIC
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES FOR
YOUTH AND ENSURING THAT.
DE INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT
RESULTS IN PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING THAT SUPPORTS THE GOALS
AND PATHWAYS FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
TO ACHIEVE EMPLOYMENT.
DATA COLLECTION AND SHARING
ACROSS DEPARTMENTS TO TRACK
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES
SELF ADVOCACY BUY IN THE
INDIVIDUAL WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR PARENTS. BY GIVING THEM
ACCESS TO NEEDED INFORMATION TO
ACHIEVE THE NECESSARY
COORDINATION ACROSS AGENCIES
AND FINALLY IT ASSURES THAT
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THIS AGREEMENT HAVE
A VOICE IN ITS IMPLEMENTATION.
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SUPPORTS AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
ONE AS IT ENSURES THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL WILL EXPERIENCE ONE
SYSTEM WITH ONE GOAL COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M TO NOW LUIS A MEMBER OF THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THE PARENT OF A
YOUNG ADULT WITH ADULT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. MY
YOUNGEST SON BEN IS A TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD WHO WANTS TO WORK.
BEN HAS A DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM HE
IS ONE OF THE MOST INTERESTING
HARD WORKING COMPASSIONATE AND
COMPASSIONATE TALENTED PEOPLE
THAT I HAVE EVER KNOWN. HE WANTS
WHAT EVERYONE WANTS TO BE
PRODUCTIVE AND CONTRIBUTING AND
VALUED AND TO BE INTEGRATED INTO
IS COMMUNITY THROUGH HIS JOB.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHO WANT TO BE
EMPLOYED SUCH AS MY SON BEN.
THERE MUST BE A COORDINATED
SEAMLESS DELIVERY OF SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS SO THEY CAN ACCESS
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AS OUTLINED IN THE
BLUEPRINT.
AND SO THAT THEY DO NOT BECOME
PART OF THE FRIGHTENING
STATISTICS THAT SHOW THEIR
LIKELIHOOD TO FALL OFF THAT
TRANSITION CLIP. TO BECOME
ISOLATED COUCH DWELLERS ARE
WORSE.
OR TO BECOME ENTANGLED IN A WEB
OF SERVICES THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO NAVIGATE.
MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCES TRYING
TO ACCESS SERVICES FOR MY SON
WITHIN THIS VERY COMPLICATED
SYSTEM. INCLUDE HAVING TO GO
THROUGH AN EXTREMELY TIME
CONSUMING STRESSFUL. UNNECESSARY
DUE PROCESS HEARING WITH MY SON
SERVICES IN WELFARE AT GREAT
RISK.
TO STRAIGHTEN OUT A SITUATION
RESULTING FROM COMMUNICATION
GLITCHES BETWEEN AGENCIES.
I WAS TOLD AFTER MANY MONTHS OF
TRYING TO STRAIGHTEN OUT THIS
AGENCY COMMUNICATION PROBLEM AND
AFTER THE RESULTING HEARING.
THAT THIS SHOULD NEVER HAVE
HAPPENED.
NO PARENT OR CONSUMERS SHOULD
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
NIGHTMARE JUST TO STRAIGHTEN OUT
AN AGENCY COMMUNICATION PROBLEM.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN THERE
THAT WHAT THAT. THERE'S A LOT
THAT CAN AND WILL GO WRONG WHEN
THREE DEPARTMENTS ARE INVOLVED
WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF A SINGLE
PROGRAM.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
ONE WILL MAKE A REALLY REALLY
GOOD IDEA COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT INTO A SUCCESSFUL
REALITY WITH THREE AGENCIES
COMMUNICATING EFFECTIVELY TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
LEAVE IT BY THE MIGHT HERE.
EVELYN I WILL HAS AND THE
SPONSORS TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL WILK FORDHAM
TO WORKING WITH THEM TO ADDRESS.
THOSE PIECES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
TRUTH ANDERSON OF THE ARK
COMMUNITY P. CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HOWEVER THERE THEM I FOR FORAGES
GROW.
THANK YOU.
PAGE EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
OF SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
I'M. HERE.
NICHOLAS LA AGAIN SUPPORT.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
EDU ANYWAY THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION.
KAY I HAVE A MOTION I DO NEED A
SECOND.
GET MOTION BUT MISSED BERMAN THE
SECOND OF AYE MR STONE.
WITHOUT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
HEARING NONE WHICH LIKE CLOSE
YES MA'AM MADAM CHAIR I JUST YOU
KNOW ALL OF THEIR TRAVELS
MEMBERS.
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE RUN ACROSS
PARENTS WITH THE CHILDREN THAT
HAVE HAD AN AN INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY AND THE
PARENTS ASK. WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO MY CHILD WHEN I'M
GONE.
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT WE CAN
START GIVING ASSURANCE TO
PARENTS THAT.
WE THE LEGISLATURE CARES WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN TO THEIR CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK REVIVAL.
THANK YOU.
WHAT THAT I DO HAVE THE EMOTION
THE SECOND?
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE
DOCTOR CHOI. DOCTOR CHOI I AND
NUMBER LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
LAST.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I BELIEVE STEP IT IS
HERE BELLS OUT FOUR ZERO
ENCLOSURE.
MISTREATMENT.
WHAT?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS WELL
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH ARE
AMONG OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
OVER THE PAST DECADE WE'VE TAKEN
STEPS TO STRENGTHEN OUR SUPPORT
AND EXTEND SERVICES UP TO THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE TO HELP POTS
FOSTER YOUTH TRANSITION INTO
ADULTHOOD.
RECENTLY WE'VE TAKEN STEPS TO
HELP FOSTER YOUTH IN CRISIS
REENTER THE SYSTEM AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY ADDRESSES A SMALL
LOOPHOLE I'M ALLOW FOSTER YOU TO
ENTER THE SYSTEM BEFORE THE AGE
OF STATE SIXTEEN. AT RECEIVING
ADOPTION ASSISTANCE OR CAN GAP
PORT REGAIN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SERVICES IF THEY'VE BEEN THE
VICTIM OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
THEIR ADOPTION OR GUARDIANSHIP
PLACEMENT HAS FALLEN APART.
TO BE CLEAR THIS IS A SMALL
SEGMENT OF OUR OVERALL FOSTER
YOUTH POPULATION BUT FOR THOSE
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE THESE SERVICES
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
WITH ACCESS TO EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE BENEFITS WE CAN GIVE THEM
THE SUPPORT AND STABILITY THEY
DESPERATELY NEED.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN YOUR STOP AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO ENSURE THE
PLANE WHICH IS CLEAR AND PROVIDE
THE COURT WITH THE DIRECTIONS
THAT THEY NEED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JIM GROSS ON
BEHALF OF GRACE A PROJECT OF THE
DAUGHTERS OF CHARITY.
AS OF THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
MENTIONED.
THIS IS A VERY SMALL POPULATION
AYE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
IN PREVIOUS LEGISLATION AYE MR
GIPSON ARE UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
OF THE FEDERAL LAW NOT ALLOWING.
DE.
EXTEND FOSTER CARE FOR THOSE
WHO ENTERED THE SYSTEM PRIOR TO
SIXTEEN THROUGH CAN GAP ADOPTION
SERVICES IT WAS NOT ADDRESSED.
ARE VERY FEW AYE CHILDREN OR
INDIVIDUAL THOUGHT OF THIS
CATEGORY BUT IS NONETHELESS VERY
IMPORTANT AGGRESSIVE LAST YEAR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUE HEARING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
HEARING NONE A I DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND.
TO PASS IT.
TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE
RUBIO EYE DOCTOR CHOI. DOCTOR
CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I.
THE BILL IS UP THANK YOU.
QUE OF THAT SEE MR MAIENSCHEIN
RIGHT HERE.
MR THURMAN.
I DON'T SEE MR HOLD ENORMOUS
MATHIS
.
OKAY I NEED A MOTION.
BEFORE WE CONTINUOUS DETERMINE
I NEED A MOTION ON.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWO ONE
ONE ONE.
BY SOME OF MEMBER QUIRK.
SECOND KICK MOTION BY A MISTER
STONE SECOND I MISSED THURMOND
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE.
I.
THE BILL IS OUT FOUR ZERO MISTER
DAMON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BEFORE YOU TO PRESENT A TWO
BILLS FIRST.
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR.
I WHICH HAS TO DO WITH
ELIGIBILITY FUNCTIONS PROVIDED.
IN OUR STATE. I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT A BE THIRTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR WHICH PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS
FROM ANY FUTURE PRIVATISATION AB
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS. FOR
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS MEDI CAL CAL
FRESH AND CAL WORKS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR COUNTY TO
PRIVATIZE ITS ELIGIBILITY
WORKFORCE WITH THE WAIVER
APPROVAL. NOTHING PREVENTS A
COUNTY FROM ASKING FOR A WAIVER
AT ANY TIME.
AND CAN BE REQUESTED WITHOUT THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE LEGISLATURE OR
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THE MARRIAGE OR CIVIL SERVICE
STATUS OF PERSONNEL WHO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY FOR SAFETY
NET PROGRAM BENEFITS IS AN
ESSENTIAL FEATURE OF SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS.
THE JOB PROTECTIONS THAT COME
WITH MARY AND POLICE SYSTEMS ARE
THE BEST WAY TO ENSURE THAT
WHISTLEBLOWING AS AN OPTION FOR
WORKERS WHEN THE PROGRAM IS NOT
WORKING AS IT SHOULD.
WHEN FOR PROFIT ENTITIES COMPETE
FOR CONTRACTS THE PRODUCTS THEY
DEVELOP AND THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED FROM CLIENTS IS DEAN
PROPRIETARY TO THE COMPANY.
EFFECTIVELY UNDERMINE THE
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE IN MONITORING
COMPLIANCE WITH CIVIL RIGHTS AND
OTHER PROGRAM RULES OR GOALS
EIGHTY THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
PROTECTS CALIFORNIANS WHO
DEPEND.
ON SAFETY NET PROGRAMS AND THE
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS
MEASURE. WITH ME TO TESTIFY AS
JESSICA BARTOLO FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE UP
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA. A
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS MUST BE
MERIT OR CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
OF THE COUNTY.
UNDER STATE UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
THAT MEDICAID AND SAP.
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS NEED TO BE
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS OF THE
COUNTY THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
REQUESTS FOR WAIVERS OF CERTAIN
A. CERTAIN PIECES OF THE
ELIGIBILITY PROCESS TO ALLOW FOR
PRIVATIZATION OF THOSE
PROPHECIES IN AND SNAP.
AND FINALLY IN THE CHARACTER
GRAHAM OTHER CURRENT REGULATIONS
REQUIRES THE.
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS TO BE A
MAYOR CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES OF
THE COUNTY. UP THIS BILL WHAT IT
DOES WOULD CODIFY THE CURRENT
PRACTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT.
WE'VE TAKE OUR CURRENT
PRACTICING CAO WORKS AND CODIFY
AND PUT IT LAW AND IT WOULD AND
IT WOULD. MAKE SURE THAT ANY
EROSION OF THESE PRACTICES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WOULD BE
PREEMPTED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE BEST A SYSTEM FOR. A
APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS OF THE
POGRAM AND AND THAT AS USED AS
YOU HEARD THE AUTHOR SAY IT
HELPS SUPPORT WHISTLEBLOWING
WHICH IS REALLY IMPORTANT ADD TO
ADVOCATES THRILLED IDENTIFY WHEN
THERE ARE PROBLEMS. AND ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PROGRAM AS
WELL HAVE FOR THESE REASONS WERE
PROUD TO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR SEIU IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSH WILL WILL GO WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JUST THINK YOUR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THAT WE HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION
ON THIS BILL AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFTEN THE
SPONSOR ON THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
PRACTICE.
AND THEN THEN VITAL ROLE THAT
COUNTY STAFF PLAY IN MAKING
THESE IMPORTANT ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS FOR THE SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS.
I'M ARE NEUTRAL POSITION IS
TAKEN I JUST OUT OF CONCERNS OF
ANY SORT OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR CODIFYING
EXISTING PRACTICE IN THE STATE
LAW IF THAT'S NOT AT RISK OF
CHANGING. AND OUT OF ANY
CONCERNS FOR POTENTIAL EXPANSION
BEYOND ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE WERE DOZENS VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANYWAY THIS IS AN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY I NEED A MOTION ANNA.
SECOND.
ALL SECOND.
OF.
CITY.
WHICH LIKED BOTH ARTISTICALLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AYE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS A TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
OF CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
RUBIO PART REVEAL I DARE TO
CHOI.
DUCKED CHOI NO ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
VARIOUS.
STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND AYE THURMOND
AYE BILLS GET THREE VOTES WHICH
ONE I THINK YOU THE BILL LOCAL.
IF YOU AND THE YET ANOTHER ONE
OF ITEM SIXTEEN I AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
PRESENTING AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY.
BUT THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENHANCE.
IT EARLY EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES AND EXPANDED
LEARNING FOR FAMILIES THAT LET
ME START BY SAYING THAT WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
MEHMET'S.
AND THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR NEAR
STAFF WHERE WORK AND HELPING US
REFINE THIS BILL.
.
THIS PORTAL THIS BILL WOULD SET
UP.
AN ONLINE PORTAL FOR EARLY
EDUCATION AND EXPAND IT LEARNING
OF THE PORTAL WILL SERVE AS A
ONE STOP SHOP FOR FAMILIES.
A TO ACCESS ELIGIBILITY
INFORMATION APPLY FOR PROGRAMS.
COMMUNICATE WITH CASEWORKERS
ONLINE ADDITIONALLY THIS WEBSITE
WOULD ALLOW FOR FAMILIES TO BE
CONNECTED TO PROVIDERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS VERY COMPLICATED TO NAVIGATE
AND KEEPS FAMILIES AND TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF. BENEFICIAL
PROGRAMS
I IN MANY CASES THERE ARE DOZENS
OF PUBLICLY FUNDED EARLY
EDUCATION CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE EACH WITH THEIR OWN
QUALIFICATIONS ENROLLMENT
PROCESS. THIS BILL CALLS FOR
CONSOLIDATION OF THOSE RESOURCES
INTO ONE ONLINE PORTAL FOR
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS TO
ACCESS.
IN ADDITION THIS PORTAL WOULD
ALLOW FOR PROVIDERS TO.
BUT TO GIVE INPUT INFORMATION
ACCESS PROFESSIONAL RESOURCES IN
ONE LOCATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WITH ME TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
EMPHASIS IS MONIQUE WHILE MOST
IMPRESSED BY CALIFORNIA AND
ROWENA KIND OF FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK.
I THINK YOU MAY KEEP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MANY CRIMINALS ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINE.
IT'S IS A CRUCIAL BILL IN A.
CRUCIAL FIRST STEP IN CREATING A
VISION FOR A DATA SYSTEM TO
CONNECT OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
AFTER SURVIVING THE DEVASTATING
CUTS FROM THE RECESSION IT'S
TIME TO EVOLVE TO A STRONGER
CONNECTED FAMILY CENTERED SYSTEM
WITH A STATEWIDE SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY ESTABLISHES
OF STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO HELP
INFORM THE DATA SYSTEM AND WE
ENVISION THE STATE OF SYSTEM
SUPPORTING AGENCIES BUT TRULY
BEING A RESOURCES. FOR PARENTS
DEFINING THE CARE THAT THAT BEST
SUITS THEIR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RWANDA COMMO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY. THE CONVENING OF A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO DEVELOP THE
COMPONENTS OF THE ONLINE PORTAL
IS CRITICAL TO INSURE THAT THE
CONNECTED INFORMATION
INFRASTRUCTURE MAKES IT EASIER
FOR PARENTS TO ACCESS THE VAST
RESOURCES. ON CHILD CARE
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO SUPPORTS OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
THE STATE MADE ITS SMALL ONE
TIME INVESTMENT IN FISCAL YEAR
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO DEVELOP
CONSUMER EDUCATION WEBSITE TO
FULFILL THE CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
REQUIREMENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK
HAS BEEN LEADING THIS WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
AGENCIES.
THE CONSUMER EDUCATION SITE MY
CHILD CARE PLAN DOT ORG IS JUST
ONE COMPONENT OF THE LARGER EAZY
E. SYSTEM OUGHT TO PROVIDE
PARENTS WITH ANOTHER ACCESS
POINT. TO GET THE CRITICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT CHILD CARE AND
EARLY EDUCATION.
IN CALIFORNIA AND TO CONNECT
THEM WITH STATE AND LOCAL
RESOURCES THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI DIANA DOMINGUEZ.
WITH CHILDCARE RESOURCE CENTER
AND CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KIT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU DANNY MICHELETTI
COOPER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM AND WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY
IN OPPOSITION WE.
.
WE'RE IN A NEUTRAL POSITION OR
HOPING TO FLIP THAT BACK TO
SUPPORT AT ONE TIME WE WERE AND
SIT IN SUPPORT NIGHT THINK WITH
CONVERSATIONS WE CAN GET BACK
THERE.
ARE ARE THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS ARE THE ONLY ENTITY
THAT ACTUALLY DO THE CASE
MANAGEMENT. AND OUR CONCERNS
SURROUND.
.
WE SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE
BILL FOR THE PROVIDER PORTAL AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION. WHERE OUR
RESERVATIONS?
ARISE.
IS BASED ON THE CENTRAL PORTAL
FOR INCOME ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATION. HISTORY HAS SHOWN
US THAT WHEN YOU DO A SYSTEM FOR
ALL FAMILIES BUT YOU DON'T
ACTUALLY RECOGNIZE THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF THE SUBSIDY FAMILIES OF
WHICH THE AP'S ARE THE ONLY
ONES.
THAT HAVE THAT UNIQUE
UNDERSTANDING.
THEN THE FAMILIES IN THE SUBSIDY
SYSTEM ARE THE ONES THAT
ACTUALLY GET HURT THEY FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
WE HAD A CENTRALIZED ELIGIBILITY
LIST BEFORE.
AND THEY WERE ALL GOOD
INTENTIONS TO GET IT GOING AND
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE FUNDING WAS LOST PEOPLE
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEM AND
FAMILIES FELL THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
SO.
ADDITIONALLY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY THEY HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS
ON THIS LANGUAGE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SECURED. LOCAL FUNDING TO
DEVELOP A PORTAL AND TO DEVELOP
A WEBSITE FOR ALL FAMILIES BUT
REALLY HEAVILY FOCUSED ON
SUBSIDY FAMILIES. SO WE SEE A
LOT OF DUPLICATION WITH WHAT
THEY'RE DOING BUT THERE HASN'T
YET BEEN A REAL ASSESSMENT.
UP WHAT IS CURRENTLY OUT THERE
SO SO AGAIN WE WANNA RAISE THAT
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THAT
PROVIDER PORTAL. AND SHARING OF
INFORMATION OUR RESERVATIONS ARE
ARE SURROUNDING HEALTH THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE INCOME
ELIGIBLE THE SUBSIDY FAMILIES.
COME INTO THE SYSTEM WE ALREADY
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS
BEAUTIFULLY ARMED WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS.
AND WE WOULD SAY.
LET LET'S BUILD ON IT BUT LET'S
NOT REPLICATE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY DOT. THE MAN THAT BRING
BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
K. HEARING THAN I NEED I DO NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU CARE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND AND THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED IT TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS. CAN YOU
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
SO I'M SORRY CAN WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES I RECOMMEND SHARE I
WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT.
WE RECOGNIZE THE INCREDIBLE
EXPERTISE SET CAPS PROVIDES TO
FAMILIES TO THAT BILL THEMSELVES
OF SUBSIDY. OUT THERE ARE
MEETINGS AT TAKING PLACE AND SET
UP TO TAKE PLACE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE.
THAT IS INCLUDED IN THIS EFFORT
HOW MY WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT
FROM A GENERAL STANDPOINT.
AS HARD AS IT IS FOR FAMILIES A
SOMETIME FUNDS RESOURCES I DON'T
THAT YOU COULD EVER HAVE A LIMIT
ON THE NUMBER OF HUESO TO HELP
THE FAMILY GET THERE. BUT I WANT
TO BE RIGHT A FRIGHTENED SAID
THAT THIS IS. IMPORTANT PARTNER
WHO DOES INCREDIBLE WORK AND WE
THINK THAT WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
GET EVERYONE I IN FALL THIS
EFFORT TO SUPPORT OUR FAMILIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABODE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DUCK TO CHOI AND GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN LAST.
REST AYE STONE STONE AYE
THURMOND AYE AYE THURMOND AYE
ALICIA FIVE ISSUE.
THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY I AM LIFTING THE CALL ON.
ITEM ELEVEN.
A. B..
THIRTY TWO ANTI.
AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE NUCLEAR
ITEM ELEVEN I NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
BUT WITH SOUND FACTORY.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR
CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI I AND NUMBER LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
THERE'S.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMAN.
MEANT I.
BILL ISN'T BY PRETTY OKAY I'LL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. THREE ZERO
ZERO SIX.
STONE.
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
GRANDSON VILLAGE OUT FORTY.
THANK YOU BELLA'S.
WHEN WE HAVE COGNITIVE.
I'M SORRY THURMOND.
WHOOPS.
OKAY THE BILL'S UP FIVE ZERO.
AND DON'T THINK COTTON ON ITEM
NUMBER TEN A. B. TWO FOUR FIVE
FIVE KALRA.
CAN CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
REYES SITE.
IT WAS OUT.
VOICE A VOICE YOUR BILL IS OUT
FOUR ZERO FOUR ONE I'M SORRY
FOUR ONE.
QUE AND.
I DON'T TWENTY THREE.
AB THREE TWO TWO FOUR EIGHT
THURMOND.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
PRESS.
REYES I BILL WAS OUT FOR CA THE
BILL'S OUT FOUR ZERO. UP FOR
ONE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN FOR ONE
STORY.
THAT'S.
ITEM NINETEEN AB THREE THREE
ZERO THREE NINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR.
IT'S HARD WORK ON THIS BILL WE
UNDERSTAND THE.
THE LET THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
BILL A BUT WE DO APPRECIATE.
WORKING WITH YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. A CONTINUED TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY THIRTY
NINE IS ONE OF THREE BILLS. IN A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PACKAGE TO
REDUCE.
BARRIERS TO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY CREATES A
FAIR CHANCE FOR PEOPLE WITH THE
REST WERE CONVICTION RECORDS TO
ACCESS CARE GIVING. AND OTHER
JOBS GOVERNED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
AB THIRTY THIRTY NINE WOULD
GRANT CLEARANCES AND ELIMINATE
THE EXEMPTION. PROCESS FOR
APPLICANTS WHO WERE CONVICTED OF
A NON DIRECTLY OR NON ADVERSELY
RELATED CRIME WITHIN THE
PRECEDING FIVE YEARS.
APPLICANTS WHO WERE CONVICTED OF
A CRIME OLDER THAN FIVE YEARS AT
THE TIME OF APPLICATION WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF VIOLENT FELONIES.
ADDITIONALLY AB THIRTY THREE
NINE WILL REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES TO BEGIN
COLLECTING DATA FROM CLARENCE AN
EXEMPTION APPLICATIONS
SPECIFICALLY DEMOGRAPHICS ON
AGE.
ETHNICITY GENDER AND CONVICTED
CRIMES FROM APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE DENIED CLEARANCE AND
EXEMPTIONS CURRENTLY THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT COLLECTED
FROM APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
DENIED OR GRANTED CLEARANCE OR
EXEMPTIONS WHICH IS A GREAT
DISSERVICE. TO THE FACILITIES
AND LEGAL CENTERS THAT FIGHT
EVERY DAY TO END THE
UNINTENTIONAL RACISM AND OUR
EMPLOYMENT SYSTEM.
THIS DATA WILL SHOW THE
CONSISTENT OPERABLE PORTION OF
MARGINALIZEDCOMMUNITIES WHO ARE
OVER POLICED AND OVER CONVICTED.
AND WILL HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
CHANGE IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM.
FURTHERMORE IT HAS BEEN SHOWN
THROUGH DATA AND STUDIES THAT
ONLY A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO DID COMMIT A CRIME.
A FEW YEARS PRIOR ACTUALLY
RECIDIVISM. PROVIDING THAT
REHABILITATION WORKS AND PEOPLE
CAN CHANGE.
FOR THIS REASON THIS BILL HAS
BEEN ENDORSED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AS IT
IS BLACK AND LATINO WOMEN WHO
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES OF A
BROKEN SYSTEM.
AS THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I'M
PERSONALLY.
COMMITTING TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE OPPOSITION TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE AND PROTECTION FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
IT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE A
CHALLENGE. TO GET EVERYONE TO
THE TABLE.
AND WITH THIS LANGUAGE WE WILL
BE ABLE TO MAKE REAL CHANGES
TOGETHER.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS A BILL AB
THIRTY THIRTY NINE WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE ONE OF OUR SPONSORS.
.
VEENA NAIK AT.
MAKE.
FROM THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER AND ALSO JOINING ME AS
OTHER DOE. AND IMPACTED DSS
APPLICANT.
THINK YEAH BEFORE WE CONTINUE I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE A NOTE THAT
AS OF FIVE THIRTY PM LAST NIGHT
AND UP UPDATE IN ABOUT ANALYSIS
FOR THIS BILL WAS RELEASED THE
UPDATED VERSION NO LONGER
CONTAIN SUGGESTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. YET WE WERE IN MY
OFFICE ITSELF FIVE THIRTY I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING AND THANK YOU FOR ARE
COMING OVER AND BEING WILLING
TO.
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT WITH THAT CAN
TAKE YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
RUBIO COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS BETH AND I CAN I AM AN
ATTORNEY AT THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER. A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY NINE PROVIDES A
FAIR CHANCE TO FORMALLY CAN
INCARCERATED APPLICANTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
CURRENTLY THE PROCESSES FOR ANY
CRIMINAL CONVICTION DESPITE AGE
OF THE CONVICTION RELATEDNESS OF
THE CONVICTION.
PRIOR WORK HISTORY OR ANY
REHABILITATION FACTORS THAT THEY
MUST GO THROUGH A LENGTHY
EXEMPTION PROCESS THAT CAN TAKE
AN AVERAGE OF SIX MONTHS OR
LONGER.
SOME OF THE CLIENTS WHO WE HAVE
HELPED TO HAD.
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS FROM OVER
FORTY YEARS BEFORE WE SEE FOLKS
WALKING THE DOOR ALL THE TIME
WITH CONNECTIONS FROM FIFTEEN
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AGO THEY'RE
STILL HAVING TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. WHETHER IT'S BEEN
JUDICIALLY DISMISSED THEY'VE
RECEIVED CLEARANCES THERE IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AS A
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT OR
THROUGH THE. BORDER BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES SOCIAL WORKERS WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO WORK IT
FACILITIES.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
PROPORTIONALLY IMPACTED OUR
WOMEN OF COLOR AS AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THE NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT LAW
PROJECT
HAS DATA AND STUDIES THAT
SUPPORT THE FINDINGS AFTER
SOMETIME.
WHETHER IT'S TEN MONTHS AFTER
RELEASE OR AT SIX TO SEVEN YEARS
AFTER RELEASE.
THE CRIMINAL RECORD IS NOT A
RELIABLE INDICATOR OF FUTURE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
AS SUCH LEGISLATURE HAS FOUND IS
IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY
TO ASSIST IN REHABILITATION AND
REMOVE IMPEDIMENTS TO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. AND AT THE
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND A NEW WAY
OF LIFE FOR INTER PROJECT IN LOS
ANGELES WE ARE VERY PROUD TO
SAY.
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CLIENTS WHO ARE SEEKING THESE
EXEMPTIONS ARE SUCCESSFUL AT THE
END OF THE DAY WHICH SUPPORTS
THE PRESUMPTION THAT DSS TENDS
TO HEAVILY SKEWED TOWARDS
DENYING THE EXEMPTION. ODDS ARE
DENIED THE APPLICATION THE FIRST
PLACE BASED ON CRIMINAL HISTORY
BUT ULTIMATELY CLEARING THE
PERSON AND ALLOWING THEM TO WORK
IN THE FACILITY. I RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS CONVERSATION WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD TO
ALLOW STAKEHOLDERS TO
PARTICIPATE AND TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE HEARING ALL VOICES AND I.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AMENDMENT
LAST NIGHT.
AND I JUST WANNA GET MY
REMAINING TIME TO MISS HEATHER.
JEFF.
HELLO COME.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY.
I'M MY NAME IS HEATHER AND THE
DSS INITIALLY TURNED ME DOWN IN
MY REQUEST A TO WORK WITH
CHILDREN.
I AM I HAD A JOB AT THE FRONT
DESK OF A SCHOOL.
I AM I REALLY ENJOYED MY WORK
THERE.
THE SCHOOL WANTED TO KEEP ME AND
I WANTED TO WORK.
THE DSS ARE SAID THAT BASED ON
MY PAST MISDEMEANORS.
AND THAT I SHOULDN'T WORK WITH
CHILDREN.
MY MISDEMEANORS ARE
APPROXIMATELY. FIVE TO TEN YEARS
AGO ALL OF WHICH I AM HAVE BEEN
CLEARED. IN COURT ON THROUGH THE
COURTS.
WHEN MR METERS ALL RESULTED FROM
MY PAST DRINKING PROBLEM.
MY DRINKING STEMMED FROM AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP AN ENORMOUS
PAIN.
AND EVENTUALLY LED ME TO
HOMELESSNESS.
THROUGH THE GRACE OF GOD I AM I
AND.
A LOT OF HARD WORK AND I HAVE
CHANGED MY LIFE AROUND AND
IMPROVED MY SITUATION.
I WILL NEVER GO BACK TO THAT LOW
POINT IN MY LIFE AGAIN.
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
HOW COME I'VE HAD MY DRINKING
UNDER CONTROL? AND MY BEHAVIOR.
IS NO LONGER A PROBLEM.
AGAIN THE COURTS HAVE DISMISSED
ALL MY CONVICTIONS.
I AM I HAVE THREE CHILDREN ONE
BE AN ARTISTIC.
I'M MY A TOP AUTISTIC SEND HOME
PRESCHOOL TEACHER.
I WANTED TO GIVE ME A JOB.
I'M. BUT I HAVE TO AND IF I CAN
GET THE DSS HAS PERMISSION TO
WORK THERE.
I WOULD LOVE TO WORK OR EVEN
VOLUNTEER.
I IN MY SON'S SCHOOL BUT I CAN'T
BECAUSE OF MY PAST MISTAKES.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT
THE DSS IS APPLICATION PROCESS
TARIQ.
QUEST PERMISSION TO WORK SHOULD
BE REVISED TO GIVE PEOPLE A FAIR
CHANCE.
CHAU.
.
WHAT THEY'RE LIKE TODAY NOT WHAT
THEY WERE IN THE PAST?
ALL OF THIS HAS BEEN.
THE DEPRESSING AND DEMORALIZING.
PROCESS.
IT MAKES IT SEEM LIKE THE DSS
DOES NOT WANT.
FIND OUT WHETHER YOU'VE CHANGED.
.
WHETHER PERSON HAS CHANGED
EXCUSE ME.
I HOPE THAT THE PROCESS
CAN BE MADE EASIER.
AND THAT PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO HAVE
MOVED PAST HOME. CARP MISTAKES.
CAN WORKING PLACES THAT WANT TO
HIRE THEM.
I FEEL THAT.
MYSELF AND OTHERS HAVE A LOT TO
OFFER.
AND ARE STILL VALUABLE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK HIM GOD BLESS.
THANK YOU.
I IT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LIZZY BEACON WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ERICA ADDING QUAN ON BEHALF OF
POLICY LINK IN THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CITY OFTEN FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINK YOU THINK
YOU.
SABINA CHRIS ANY WITH ALL OF US
ARE NONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHN MAYER EASE BETWEEN LAW
CENTER WE GOT A COALITION OF
FIFTEEN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AS A DALLAIRE WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN AS THEIR COALITION
CALIFORNIA WILL FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KING ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
DO YOU MIND LETTING OUR CITIES
THANK.
BOTTOM CHERRY JUST CURIOUS WHAT
THE AMENDMENT IS.
THE AMENDMENT IS ESSENTIALLY TO
CONTINUE AND YOU ARE I'M SORRY
I'M AMY SKI ACTIONS WHO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK OKAY IT IS
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
DEPARTMENT OUTSIDE DSS BUT ALSO
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OTHERS
WHO HAD QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
BILL THERE WAS CLEARLY AN
OPPORTUNITY.
THAT WE WERE REACHING OUT TO DSS
TO THIS PROCESS TO GET THEM TO
THE TABLE.
PARADED REASONS THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN AND SO WE'RE NOT. OF
MINIMIZING SOME OF THE THE
ISSUES AND CONCERNS. OF THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BUT GIVEN
THE TIMEFRAME WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO AT LEAST KEEP THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD. AND TO BE ABLE TO.
INTEGRATE YES COMMITTEES
CONCERNS I GUESS WHAT WHAT
CLARIFICATION THE BILL IN PRINT
IS WHAT WHAT WHAT I IS IN THE
FACT. THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT WE.
.
THE V. NECK DOWN.
AND SO WE'RE MOVING THE BILL AS
IT AS IT IS WITH THE ASSURANCES
FROM.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT WERE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE SS
OKAY SO AGAIN I'M KEY IS TO INTO
A FROM THAT CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORK.
AND I PUT OUR.
.
OUR CONCERNS IN OPPOSITION IS
BASED ON WHAT IS IN PRINT COME
BECAUSE WE DO FEEL LIKE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED
THAT IT LIKELY WILL ADDRESS BUT.
TODAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S
HERE.
SO I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS WHAT
OUR CONCERNS ARE.
AND.
SO THE NETWORK IS NAMED IN
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE.
TO PERFORM CERTAIN FUNCTIONS
RELATED TO CALIFORNIA'S TRUST
LINE BACKGROUND CHECK.
SO WE'VE CONTRACTED WITH EITHER
DSS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
I'M SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO TO
PERFORM THESE FUNCTIONS AND THEY
WERE VERY FAMILIAR WITH CSS
SAYS.
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS SO WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH THE BILL AS INTENSE
AS DESCRIBED BY THE SPONSOR AND
DESCRIBED BY ON THE AUTHOR BUT
AS THE LEGISLATION IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN IT PRIORITIZES
SUPPORTING ADULT MONEY TO BE A
CAREGIER OVER PROTECTING
CHILDREN IN CHILD CARE. AND.
ARRANGEMENTS ELIMINATES SIXTY
SERIOUS CRIME CATEGORIES THAT
ARE NOW CONSIDERED NON EXEMPT A
BALL WHICH INCLUDES FELONY
CONVICTIONS OF MURDER.
WILLFUL CHILD CRUELTY OR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS WITH
CONVICTIONS FOR ANY OF THESE
CRIMES ARE AUTOMATICALLY DENIED
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE CHILD
CARE. AND THAT BILL WOULD
REQUIRE DSS TO CONSIDER
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF THE
SERIOUS AND OFTEN VIOLENT
FELONIES FOR AN EXEMPTION AND
POTENTIALLY ALLOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN.
THE BILL ALSO LIMITS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO LOOK AT
CONVICTIONS AND PATTERNS OF
CONVICTIONS AS WAS DESCRIBED
EARLIER.
STILL FOR CRIMINAL CONVICTION
FROM SIX YEARS OR TEN YEARS OR
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
COULD WOULD.
PUT A CHILD AT RISK THEY'D HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO INITIALLY
DENIED THAT IT INDIVIDUAL FROM
BEING A CHILD CARE PROVIDER AND
REQUIRE THAT INDIVIDUAL GO TO
THE EXEMPTION PROCESS AND
REQUEST A HEARING IF NECESSARY.
AND IT FINALLY SEAT CDS THIS IS
ABILITY TO LOOK AT ALL TYPES OF
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS BY ONLY
ALLOWING CRIMES THAT ARE
DIRECTLY AND.
ADVERSELY RELATED CRIMES.
WHEN A CHILD'S WELL BEING IS AT
STAKE DSS SHOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO TAKEN CAN.
CONSIDERATION OF PERSONS IN FULL
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND DETERMINED
BASED ON THE SPECIFICS OF EACH
CONVICTION IF THAT INDIVIDUAL
COULD POSE A REST THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF A CHILD.
AS PROPOSED THE BILL DOES IT
MAKE MAJOR CHANGES TO THE
PROCEDURE FOR LICENSING FOSTER
FAMILY HOMES WEEK EXTRA WE
SUPPORT THAT AM STRONGLY. BUT WE
KNOW THAT ALL CHILDREN WHETHER
THEY'RE CARED FOR IN A FOSTER
HOME OR IN A CHILDCARE
ARRANGEMENT DESERVE THAT SAME
BACKGROUND CHECK PROTECTIONS.
THEY CURRENTLY RECEIVE.
UNDER LAW.
SO AS WE SAID WE AND.
WITH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WE
REALLY WE SUPPORT AND THE IDEA
OF REVIEWING AND IMPROVING
INCREASING THE EFFICIENCY AND
TIMELINESS OF THE EXEMPTION
PROCESS. AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A WORK GROUP OR
TASK FORCE AND THAT INCLUDES ALL
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS GROUPS PARENT ADVOCACY
GROUPS AND EVERY STAKEHOLDER IN
THIS PROCESS. UP TO BE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH THE SOLUTION.
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FOR DSS
WHICH COULD INCLUDE CHANGES TO
THE EVALUATOR MAP MANUAL
TRAINING PROCEDURES OR OTHER
CHANGES UP TO AND INCLUDING
STATUTE.
THANK YOU I'M AND JUST AGAIN FOR
CLARIFICATION.
THOUGH THE REASON THAT WE.
DECIDED TO PUT PUT IT THERE WAS
BECAUSE WE HAD NOT HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE SS AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING AND
SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
HOLDEN.
ASSURED ME THAT HE THAT THAT
WOULD HAPPEN AND SO FOR WHATEVER
REASON THE CONVERSATION.
DSS NEVER CAME TO THE TABLE AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THAT WITH THEM WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THE ACTIVE
PEOPLE SO THINK I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS.
AND IF I COULD THE THE ISSUES
THAT TO RELATE YOU REFERRED TO
ON THE NOT EXCEPT WE.
I THINK IT'S OUR INTENTION TO
ACCEPT THAT AND TO THE BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE CRIMES ARE.
ARE YOU ARE NOT OR MEASURED
APPROPRIATELY AND SO.
EVEN WERE ON THE SAME PAGE I
THINK THAT.
THANK
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
.
I AM LAURIE FURSTENFELD A NAME
AS SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
CHILDCARE LAW CENTER.
AND AT LAKE THE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL NETWORK WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THE INTENT OF EP
THIRTY THREE NINE TO CREATE A
MORE EQUITABLE. PROCESS FOR
PERSONS WITH AN ARRESTOR
CONVICTION HAS STRAIGHT DO HAVE
A FAIR CHANCE OF EMPLOYMENT AND
THAT THEY ARE NOT. UNFAIRLY
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND WE
HAVE ALSO SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION AND LASTS AMENDED.
I'M BASED ON THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. ON WE DO
FEEL THAT THIS THE AT THIS
INTENT ALSO NEEDS TO BE BALANCED
BUT THE RIGHTS OF CHILDREN TO BE
CARED FOR. AND IT'S SAFE
ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
OPPOSE THE BILL UNLESS AMENDED.
I'M CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY RANKS
AT THE VERY BOTTOM FOR OVERSIGHT
OF CHILDCARE LICENSE FACILITIES
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES.
AND THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF
CHILDCARE HAS WORKED ARGUE
WESLEY OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
TO REALLY IMPROVE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS OF CHILDCARE.
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
CHILDCARE LISTENER HAS BEEN I'M
AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN
SUPPORTING THESE MEASURES TO
INCREASE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
WE COULDN'T FIND ANY DATA AND
THE AGENCY SPONSOR CAN OFFER ANY
RESEARCH THAT WOULD. GUARANTEE
THAT ROOM I'M SCALING BACK THE
CRIMINAL I'M BACKGROUND
REQUIREMENTS WE KEEP CHILDREN
JUST TO SAY FOR IF NOT SAFER
AND.
I'M I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT ELIMINATING THE LIST OF NON
ACCEPTABLE CRIMES ALSO COMPLEX.
BUT THE FEDERAL FUNDING
CONDITIONS UNDER THE CHILD TO
DAYCARE. THE CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT OUR
LARGEST SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
CHILDCARE IN THE STATE AND ALSO
PROVISIONS OF THAT TITLE FOR E.
FUNDING SOURCE FOR CHILDCARE.
YOU THINK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICE ANDERSON WITH THE ARE
CAN YOU SEE P. CALIFORNIA CAR
RACING WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL AT THIS
TIME.
BUT WE HAVE TALKED TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
TO ENSURE THAT.
.
ALL VULNERABLE POPULATIONS OF
PROTECTIVENESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHERS GET HEARING ANOTHER
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
YOU'RE WORKING ON A REALLY
COMPLEX BUT VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
.
YOU AND I ARE JOINT AUTHORS ON
A. B. ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT FROM
LAST YEAR.
AND I'M ALSO OFFERING A BILL.
.
SPONSORED BY THE SAME COALITION
AND A WORKING ON THE SAME
SUBJECT.
SECOND CHANCES.
WITHOUT A DOUBT I'M FROM
BELIEVER IN SECOND CHANCES.
I MENTIONED TO YOU EARLIER THAT.
I I THINK THAT.
IT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
ADEQUATELY PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
PACIFIC WITH CHILDREN AS WAS
BEING TALKED ABOUT.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE VIOLENT
FELONIES AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
ALREADY WORKING ON THAT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE WORKING FURTHER OWN THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS AND I WANT TO
OFFER MY OFFICE.
AS A RESOURCE TO YOU AS YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAKEHOLDERS.
I WANT.
TO ENSURE THAT THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS REGARDING VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS.
PACIFIC WE THE CHILDREN ARE
DRESSED
SO THAT WE GET THE BILL RIGHT
AND I'VE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU BECAUSE. THIS IS PART
OF AN ENTIRE COALITION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO PROVIDE SECOND
CHANCES.
THANK.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
BUT CHOI.
THAT I SHARE THOSE LAWS SAYING
MCCARTY CERN ARE.
IS ALWAYS OF COURSE IN CRIMES.
WHEN WE.
BUT ALLOW.
THE.
EMPLOYMENT POURED.
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE FIVE YEARS.
WITH THAT THERE HAS BEEN NO I
THINK I HEARD THAT THERE'S NO.
STATISTICS HERE IS THAT.
TRUE THAT.
.
PREVIEWS SO.
THREATEN OFFENDERS SO IT WOULD
NOT THAT RECALL MEET THE SAME
INNER.
CRIME.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SUCH DATA.
THAT THE BY EXTENDING FIVE YEARS
IS NOT A MAGICAL.
UP PERIOD.
NOW THERE IS TO MORE FOR HUMAN
CHARACTER WILL A TENDENCY. SOME
MAY CHANGE.
SOME MAY STILL RETAIN. ITS A
FIVE YEARS OR SIX YEARS.
SO HOW CAN YOU BE SURE JUST
BECAUSE SO WHY NOT THREE YEARS
WHY NOT TWO YEARS.
SO WHERE DID YOU COME BOB COME
UP WITH A FIVE YEAR.
PERIOD.
WHAT WE'RE WORKING OFF OF THE?
?
STANDARD WHICH IS SEVEN YEARS.
FOR PRIVATE.
INSTITUTION SO WERE.
WERE WERE SORT OF LOOKING AT
THAT IT'S USING THAT AS SORT OF
A BENCHMARK.
I THINK IT'S WHAT WE'RE ALSO
TRY LOOKING FOR DSS TO DO IS TO
START TO.
COLLECT DATA SO THAT WILL HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW.
.
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES AND
INDIVIDUALS AND CHARACTER OR
PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT DATA TO HELP US.
WE HAD IT WOULD MAKE THIS A
LITTLE BIT EASIER PRESENTATION
THIS AFTERNOON BUT I THINK WHAT
WE'RE HOPING IS THAT. ARE WE CAN
HAVE THEM MOVE FORWARD GOING
FORWARD.
TO.
LOOK AT THE VARIOUS DEMOGRAPHIC.
CHARACTERISTICS AND HELP TO
START TO PROFILE. AYE IF YOU
WILL.
HOW?
THESE POPULATIONS ARE IMPACTED
AND WE'RE USING A STANDARD ON
THE SEVEN YEARS TO THAT OR USE
IT FIVE YEARS BUT SEVEN YEARS AS
THE. HEAD OF THE BENCHMARK BUT.
TURN TO THE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
AFTER CHOI JUST TO TALK ABOUT IT
FROM THE EARLIER SIDE OF THINGS.
THERE'S ACTUALLY DATA THAT
SUPPORTS THAT TEN MONTHS AFTER
RECIDIVISM.
YOUR RATE OF RECIDIVISM DROPS BY
HALF A NOTS SUBSEQUENTLY
CONTINUES TO DROP EVERY TEN
MONTHS. THERE'S ALSO DATA FROM
THE NATIONAL PLAN A LOT PROJECT
THAT STATE SIX TO SEVEN YEARS
AFTER CONTACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHERE YOU HAVE HAD
NO CONTACT IN THE INTERVENING
YEARS. YOUR RECORD IS THE SAME
AS SOMEBODY ELSE WITHOUT A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION AND THE RATE
OF RECIDIVISM IS MINIMAL IN
COMPARISON TO SOMEONE WITHOUT A
RECORD.
I'M AS I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN MENTIONED THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS UNDER. THE LABOR
CODE PROVISIONS WHERE I'VE
EMPLOYERS CANNOT CONSIDER
CONVICTIONS PAST SEVEN YEARS
THERE'S ALSO.
WASH UP PERIODS IN THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
LAWS WHERE THEY LIMITED TO TEN
YEARS SO WE SETTLED ON FIVE IS
SOMETHING THAT FELT LIKE IT WAS
IN THE MIDDLE OF SEVEN YEARS.
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
DATA THAT SUPPORTS THAT TEN
MONTHS AFTER A CONVICTION IF
SOMEBODY HAS NOT RECIPROCATED
THEIR RATE OF RECIDIVISM HAS
ALREADY DROPPED FIFTY PERCENT
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DROP.
AND JUST TO NOTE THAT HAVING
EMPLOYMENT IS THE STRONGEST
PREDICTOR.
TO.
FURTHER PREVENTING RECIDIVISM.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR.
YEAH I I THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO I I WAS JUST
HOPING THAT YOU
COULD CLARIFY I HAD TROUBLE
FOLLOWING THE.
.
WE DO ANY AMENDMENTS FOR NOT
DOING THE AMENDMENT SO WHAT THAT
REALLY MEANS AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON IT. I DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THAT REFERS TO.
AND AND I'M JUST WONDERING IF WE
COULD JUST IF SOMEONE COULD JUST
SAY.
I'M KIND OF A SIMPLE PURSUITS
MEDINA SAY IN PLAIN LANGUAGE
THAT.
.
IT. GOES AMENDMENTS SPEAK TO IF
A PERSON HAS EVER COMMITTED A
CRIME THAT WAS RELATED TO THE
HARMING OF A CHILD. IS THAT
WOULD THAT. DISQUALIFY THEM FROM
THIS CONSIDERATION OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT COULDN'T BE
REVIEWED UP PERHAPS YOU COULD
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY SO THAT.
WERE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE ABOUT
WHAT'S MEANT THAT NOT AMENDED OR
WE'RE HEADED BY A FAIR ENOUGH OF
WHAT WE PRESENTED AS OUR BILLS
MOVING INTO THIS COMMITTEE IS
WHAT IS BEFORE YOU. THE
COMMITTEE.
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
MADE SOME ADDITIONAL.
SUGGESTIONS AND THAT WAS ONE OF
THEM AND WE HAVE EVERY INTENTION
OF OF MOVING FORWARD AND TAKING
THAT WE WANTED TO.
DO IS MOVE THE THE BILL FORWARD
BECAUSE THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
PIECES THAT NEED TO BE ADJUSTED
AND WE WANTED TO GET DSS IS THEN
PUT ON.
A LOT OF THIS CONVERSATION HICH
WE HAVE NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO. I THINK I'M UP TO SPEED
IF I IF I HEARD IT TELL ME IF I
HEARD IT WRONG BUT WHAT YOU SAID
YOU KNOW WORK WITH THE EXCESS
DSS AND. THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN
THE CHAIR AND THAT YOUR INTENT
IS TO ARTICULATE SOME TYPE OF A
POLICY THAT IF THE CRIME WAS
SPECIFICALLY COMMITTED TO
ENDANGERMENT ARE HARMING A
CHILD.
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
REVIEWED.
DID I HEAR RIGHT GUESTBOOK ALL
VOTER BILL POPULATIONS BUT ALL
GOVERNOR LIGHTLY AS IT RELATES
TO THE TESTIMONY UNDERSTOOD VERY
HELPFUL THANK YOU MEN CHAIR LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. CAN
HAVE A MOTION.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN
AFFECTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO AS
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS IF
YOU CAN GET A LITTLE PLEASED A
I'M SORRY DE ONE CLOSELY.
ARE YOU KNOW I THINK I I THINK
THAT WOULD BE MY CLOTHES I JUST
SAY THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE OUT
TO THE COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORKING WITH US ON THIS.
THANK YOU AND I ACCEPT A.
SENATE RACES OFFER ALSO TO.
TO BE A PART OF THIS CHICAGO
THEIR OFFICE STAFF FIRST YEAH.
IF YOU THINK ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY
A LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE IN THE
OTHER COMMITTEE YOU WERE
ACTUALLY RUBIO AND YOU YES.
THANK YOU CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE REVEALED.
REVIEW I DIRECTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI IN KNOW ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
CLASS.
THIS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND I WAS JUMPED
WELL ALLOWED FOR ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MATHIS
WELCOME MR METHODS.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT EIGHTY
B. THE NINETEEN NINETY. A BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE AFFORDABLE AND
INTEGRATED HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
OUR INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENT
LEAD DISABLED COMMUNITIES.
AS YOU ARE AWARE THE STATE'S
REMAINING DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
WILL BE CLOSING BY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE.
AS SUCH THE CURRENT RESIDENTS OF
THE CENTERS WILL BE
TRANSITIONING. INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ARE IN NEED OF
HOUSING OPTIONS.
IN ADDITION MANY AT ALL REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENTS CURRENTLY LIVING
IN THE COMMUNITY ALSO STRUGGLE
TO FIND AFFORDABLE AND
INDEPENDENT HOUSING OPTIONS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF ADULT
RESULTS IN OUR CLIENTS
RELY SOLELY ON SSI OR SSB.
FOR THEIR INCOME AT A MAXIMUM OF
NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN DOLLARS PER
MONTH.
AVERAGE RATE FOOD.
HEALTHCARE COSTS EXEDRA.
OFTEN EXCEED THIS AMOUNT.
THIS PRESENTS REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS WITH FEW OPTIONS FOR
INDEPENDENT HOUSING.
HOUSING AS ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STATE.
AND THE SITCH WAY XIN IS
EXPRESSLY DIRE.
FOR. OUR PEOPLE
WITH.
S. ABILITIES.
WHO OFTEN RELY AGAIN ON SSI OR
S. SP AS THEIR ONLY SOURCE OF
INCOME?
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
COMMUNITY PROVIDERS ARE
REPORTING THAT NEAR.
AND POSSIBILITY OF SECURING
HOUSING FOR THEIR CLIENTS.
AS WELL AS.
THE DEVASTATING STORIES OF
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ALREADY HAVE
HOUSING?
WHO HAVE ALREADY LOST THEIR
DUE TO ITS INCREASE PRICES.
AS SUCH.
MORE MUST BE DONE TO PROVIDE
THESE INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
OPTION TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
CURRENTLY A PORTION
OF THE SITE AND FARED VIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
IS RUN AS HARD WILL VILLAGE.
A MIX RESIDENT COMMUNITY WHICH
SERVES.
A. MANDATED PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THIS MODEL HAS PROVEN EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE AT PROVIDING HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
TRANSFERRING OUT OF THE STATE'S
REMAINING DC'S.
AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS ALREADY
AND THE COMMUNITY IN NEED OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FURTHERMORE THE SITES HAVE BEEN
FOUND
TO GENERATE SURPLUS REVENUES.
WHICH ARE ULTIMATELY FUNNELED
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES DDS.
TO INCREASE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL.
S. ABILITIES.
UTILIZING AN EXPANDING UPON THIS
MODEL. AB NINETEEN NINETY WILL
ESTABLISH.
CALIFORNIA INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
THE LIVING PROGRAM
WITHIN DTS.
THIS PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE LOANS
TO COVER THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CONSTRUCTION AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
ULTIMATELY THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT THE FUNDING CURRENTLY
PROVIDED TO OUR INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL.
DISABLED HUMIDITY REMAINS WITH
THE CLIENTS
RATHER THAN RETURNING.
TO THE GENERAL FUND.
MEMBERS THIS IS KEY. WE CANNOT
ALLOW THIS VITAL FUNDING TO BE
TAKEN AWAY.
FOR MORE DISABLED COMMUNITY.
RATHER WE SHOULD PROACTIVELY
CAPTURE AND UTILIZE THESE FUNDS
TO ENSURE ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
HOUSING OPTIONS.
FOR OUR DISABLED COMMUNITY.
ALONG WITH.
RESIDENTS CURRENTLY IN NEED OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS.
WITHOUT THE PROACTIVE APPROACH
OUTLINED WITHIN THIS MEASURE
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL CONTINUE
TO BE OSTRACIZED.
WITH ME TODAY MISS PATTY UP
LINGER.
WHEN HOUSING NOW
AND THE WIND AMID HOUSING
ALLIANCE
PATTY.
I THINK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
MADAM CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE.
PADDY UP LONGER AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
NOW WERE LOCAL COULD RECOVER TEN
COUNTIES AND PROVIDE HOUSING
RESOURCES FOR THIS PARTICULAR
POPULATION. WERE ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE LANTERN IN HOUSING
ALLIANCE WHICH IS A STATEWIDE
GROUP THAT DOES HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE WITH IDT. AND IT. YOU YOU
HEAR IT THE HOUSING CRISIS IT IS
TREMENDOUS OUT THERE THESE FOLKS
IN THIS BOOK ON LEGACY. I WAS AT
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORKING PROVIDED A THREE
HOUSING SESSIONS FOR PEOPLE IN
ATTENDANCE THESE ARE LUCKY ONES
LUCKY FOLKS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ABLE TO. AVOID AN
INSTITUTION AND LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT IT'S REALLY IT'S
REALLY REALLY GETTING VERY
DIFFICULT AND I CAN.
BUT I CAN PAINT THE PICTURE OF
THE HOUSING MARKET JUST IN
JANUARY I WAS PREPARING FOR AN
INTERVIEW AND I TALKED AS A
HOUSING SPECIALIST I'M ALSO
HOUSING SPECIALIST FOR THIS
POPULATION. I TALKED TO AN
AGENCY AND THEY SAID WELL PATTY
ABOUT FIFTEEN PEOPLE THAT NEED
TO FIND HOUSING BY MARCH THE
REASON IS BECAUSE THE LANDLORDS
MAYBE APARTMENTS ARE UNDER NEW
OWNERSHIP. NO LONGER WILL ACCEPT
THE HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHER
PROGRAM AS WELL AS PEOPLE ARE
PRICED OUT SPECIALLY IN
SACRAMENTO WE HAD THE HIGHS
HIRES RISING RENTS IN THE.
NATION LAST YEAR SO PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SHOULD BE ABLE TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY I HAVE AN EXAMPLE OF A
PERSON. THAT CINEMAS ON THE WAY
BEING CLOSED DOWN CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER IN THIS
INDIVIDUAL WHO WANTS TO LIVE IN
NEEDS TO MOVE INTO THE COMMUNITY
WERE HAVING TROUBLE WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR MONTHS TO TRY AND
FIND APPROPRIATE HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR HIM. LIKE A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED THIS
MOST PEOPLE THAT WE TRY TO FIND
HOUSING FOR OUR AND SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS JUST IN SACRAMENTO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY A ONE BEDROOM
IS NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
DOLLARS. IF YOU DON'T HAVE SOME
SORT OF SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE IT IN
THE COMMUNITY THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPETITION FOR THESE RESOURCES
THE VERY LIMITED RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE. THAT SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
WHETHER IT'S HOUSING CHOICE
VOUCHERS OR TAX CREDIT
PROPERTIES ARE BOND HOUSING OR
OTHER SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THAT'S
DEEPLY SUBSIDIZE FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE. EXTREMELY LOW INCOME THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED THIS MONEY HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND AS THESE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS CLOSE THE
MONEY. SHOULD FOLLOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS INTO THE COMMUNITY
TO PROVIDE APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES FOR THEM AS FAR AS
THEIR HOUSING IS CONCERNED SO.
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN
LEVERAGE SOME OF THIS FUNDS TO.
UP MARY WITH THE TAX CREDITS AND
AND MAKE IT COMPETITIVE SO THAT
WE GET MORE OF HOUSING SET ASIDE
FOR THIS POPULATION EVEN NO
PLACE LIKE HOME MONEY THAT'S FOR
PEOPLE
MENTAL ILLNESS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE A MENTAL
ILLNESS SO WE NEED FUNDING AND
WE NEED HOUSING NOW AND I ASK
YOU RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS CINDY JACKSON FROM
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES ARCA ANARCHISM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THREE THE ANDERSON WITH THE ARK
IN UCP CALIFORNIANSSUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THEY'RE GETTING THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AT IT WHEN IT'S AN
OPPOSITION.
CATERING NONE OF MOVE A BRING IT
UP TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT JUST TO COMMENT ON THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS LIKE I
THANK YOU FOR TAKING A PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO THIS.
IT'S CLEARLY GOING TO BECOME A
PROBLEM IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
AND. I I THINK YOU'VE COME UP
WITH A GOOD SOLUTION TO IT BY I
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WITH THAT
I MOVE THE BILL. THINK.
OKAY HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMAN.
THE CONDUCT THAT CHIU CHOI.
SEE WHICH LIKE CLOTHES.
OUR YES MEMBERS. A AGAIN THIS IS
OF VITAL IMPORTANCE THAT I JUST
WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR.
YOU KNOW IT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A POPULATION THAT'S BEEN TAKING
CARE OF IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AND AS AS REALIGNMENTS
HAPPENING.
THE HOUSING THAT THEY'VE BEEN.
NEW.
AT IS NO LONGER GOING TO BE
THERE'S THIS.
INSURERS THAT AS THEY'RE MOVING
INTO THE COMMUNITY THE FUNDING
IS FOLLOWING THEM.
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND
ON TOP OF THAT.
WE ALL KNOW.
THAT.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS WE HAVE
THESE ISSUES GOING ON IN THIS
GIVES QUITE FRANKLY THE ABILITY.
AND AND I'VE BEEN DOWN HARPER
VILLAGE IT'S A BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS
BUT IT GIVES US THE ABILITY. IN
EACH ONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO
DEVELOP OUR OWN HARBOR VILLAGE
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN DISABLED
POPULATIONS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ARM TO TRULY BRING THE MAN TRULY
INTEGRATE THEM AND TREAT THEM.
HOW THEY DESERVE AND THAT WOULD
HAVE ACCESS?
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING CELL
WITHOUT ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE I'M ALSO OPEN FOR.
CO AUTHORS AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I HAVE A MOTION IN
THE SECOND AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
ASSEMBLY A PREPARATION. CAN YOU
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE REVIEW AYE
REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
PLAYERS.
THIS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
THE BILL ITSELF.
OKAY THE BILL'S OUTSIDE THING
YOU THINK YOU OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAINTAINED.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION.
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SONGS AFFECT
MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AND IN LIGHT OF
THE MOTION OF THE SECOND I'LL BE
BRIEF I I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
WHEN HOUSEHOLD INCOMES ARE
ENOUGH TO MEET BASIC NEEDS
TEMPORARY AID FROM CAL FRESH CAN
OFTEN BRIDGE THE GAP TO. GAP IN
FACT IT'S ONE OF OUR NATION'S
MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS AGAINST
HUNGER IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY ALONE
NEARLY SIXTY THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS
ENROLLED IN MEDICARE HOW.
THROUGH CAL HERE'S IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
COVER CALIFORNIA'S ONLINE
APPLICATION PORTALS A PRIMARY
WAY.
THAT CAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS APPLY FOR MEDI CAL
HEALTH BENEFITS A BEAST THIRTY
THIRTY THREE WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS APPLYING FOR MEDI
CAL THROUGH COVERED CALIFORNIA
WHO ALSO WISH TO APPLY FOR CAO
FRESH BENEFITS. TO HAVE THEIR
APPLICATION QUALIFY FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS BY USING THE EXISTING
SYSTEMS TO STREAMLINE THE CAL
FRESH PROCESS. WE CAN MAKE IT
EASIER FOR ELIGIBLE PEOPLE IN
NEED ACCESS FOOD. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BELLAS
KEVIN AS ONE IN THERE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COUPLE A
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THINK.
YOU'RE GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN
ETHICAL OR SUCCUMB AFFORDABLE
FOR RIGHTS ORGANIZATION OF THE
VERY LENGTHY. THIS IS A VERY
GOOD BILL.
MAKES A MORE EFFICIENT YET TO
AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UP ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
K. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I'LL ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
.
WHICH LIKE THAT THANK YOU MEANT
CHAIR RESPECT REQUEST AYE BUT.
THANK YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE DARTED.
DUTCH CHOI I AND NUMBER LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN HYATT
AIRS.
THERE'S AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
VILLAGE DOUBT.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO.
THANK YOU AND MITRE
.
YOU CAN PUT FROM.
NINE.
OKAY ASSEMBLYMAN RUBIO THANK YOU
DID NOT KNOW ONE EIGHTY THREE
YES.
YES BUT ACTUALLY CAN WE START
WITH TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX PLEASE.
I HAVE TWO BILLS CAN WE START
WITH TWENTY THREE LEFT OR HAD
THE THINGS AND ONE NOT PHONE ONE
EIGHTY THREE. OH THREE TWENTY
SIX.
YEAH SO NUMBER NUMBER SIX FORCE.
NEITHER YOU KNOW SHE WANTS TO
KNOW INTERPERSONAL HER SORE.
TWENTY SIX.
RIGHT WITNESSES ARE HERE FOR
TWENTY FIVE FOR TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX OKAY
UNIT TO OUR AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SIX YES THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS TO DAM.
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SIX WHICH ALLOWS PARENTS
OR CAREGIVERS WHO HAVE A CHILD
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF AGE OR
YOUNGER. AND PREGNANT WOMEN WHO
ARE THE SOLE MEMBERS OF THEIR
ASSISTANT UNITS TO BE EXEMPTED
FROM THE CAL WORKS WELL FOR TO
WORK EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM AND
INSTEAD GIVEN THEM. GIVING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY THE THE OPTION
TO VOLUNTEER TO PARTICIPATE.
AS A NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED INFANCY IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME FOR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S THIS BILL
COMES IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
IMPORTANT ROLE WE KNOW EARLY
BONDING TIME CAN HAVE ON A
CHILD'S LONG TERM HEALTH.
BY EXEMPTING THESE CAO WORK
FAMILIES FROM WELFARE TO WORK
ACTIVITIES AND IT'S THAT
PROVIDING THEM WITH THE OPTION
OF VOLUNTEERING WHERE EMPOWERING
THEM WITH THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR OWN
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND FOR
THE NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILIES.
HERE TODAY.
IS OUR SPONSOR A CABIN PASSED
LAN I. WITH THE COALITION OF
COKE BOTTLES WHEN YOU OFFER
RIGHTS AND MICHELLE.
THEY'RE WELL.
I CAMPUS.
.
I.
AND THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE THANK
YOU.
YOU'RE GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN
ETHICAL RESEARCH CALIFORNIA WITH
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THE FEAR THE FEAR OF A BABY FROM
FOR TWELVE MONTH ACCOUNT A
TWELVE WEEK THE COUNTY MAY
EXEMPT TO.
THEY MAY EXTEND THAT SIX MONTHS.
AND THEN YOU CAN ALSO BE EXEMPT
FOR TWENTY FOUR MONTH WITH VERY
VERY COMPLEX ALSO IF YOU HAVE A
IF YOU NINETEEN YEARS OLD TO
HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA. YOU
GET ALL EXEMPTION ALL.
AND YOU GET SANCTION IF YOU GIVE
BIRTH TO YOUR BABY ON THURSDAY
YOU DON'T GO TO WORK FOR THE
NEXT THING YOU CAN GET
SANCTIONED IT TO BE PICKED
PROPONENTS FOR THE TH.
SO THIS SIMPLE EARTH SURPRISED
WITH PROFITS
MATHIS ANYBODY WHO HAVE A CHILD
UNDER THE AGE OF. A TWO.
SHOP BE EXEMPT HOWEVER THEY ALSO
GET A BIGGER NOTICING THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE EXEMPT AND ALSO
PLAN WHERE THEY CAN VOLUNTEER TO
PARTICIPATE THEY CAN INDICATE ON
THEIR. WHAT THEY WANT TO DO THEM
WHEN THEY WANT TO DO IT IN
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS THE COUNTY
HAS TO PROVE THAT?
OPPOSE PLAN IN ADDITION TO READ
EVERY SIX MONTHS WHEN THEY GET A
NOTICE.
OF OF OF REPORT TO M. BUT THE
CALL INCOME REPORTS EVERY SIX
MONTHS THEY ALSO GIVEN
NOTIFICATION THAT THE KEBAB INTO
TO PARTICIPATE.
AND THAT ALSO HAPPENS ANNUALLY.
SO THIS IS TO SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS
INVITE KNOW. UNDER CURRENT LAW.
M. IF YOU WANT TO BE EXEMPT YOU
COULD BE THE ARE YOU HAVE TO IS
CALLING A WORKER AND BE EXEMPT.
BUT THAT TAKES A.
BUT THAT THAT'S BUREAUCRATICALLY
COMPETENT COME BUT CUMPLIR
CUMBERSOME NO COST MONEY THIS
WILL SAVE MONEY AND WITH SIMPSON
PROVIDE THE PROFITS.
AND I WOULD DRIVE VOTE THANK
YOU.
I AM MICHELLE STILL PREVENTS HE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA.
HERE IN SUPPORT.
WE KNOW THAT THE FIRST FEW YOU
TWO YEARS OF LIFE ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR FOR OUR INTENSE.
NEW PARENTING IS VERY HARD AND
THOSE CHALLENGES ARE COMPOUNDED
BY DEEP POVERTY I'M WE SHOULD BE
PROVIDING. FAMILIES THAT ON THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM.
WITH.
THE OPTION TO.
HAVE THE TIME TO BOND WITH
THEIR CHILD.
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT IS.
IS EFFECTIVE FOR.
HOPING THAT CHILD DEVELOP IN
THE WAY THAT WE WANT TO.
ALLOWING THE FAMILIES TO THEM
MOTHERS TO BE ABLE TO BREASTFEED
IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO ON ALL
OF THESE ARE OPTIONS THAT OUR
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
URGING AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I'M JIM MOVED IN THE SECOND DAY
THAT ANY OF THOSE PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
ANNIE OUR MEMBERS SELECT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION.
.
NOW I KNOW.
SINCE I I JUST BECAME OUR.
.
WHEN FATHER.
MY DAUGHTER WITH THE BABY. AND.
JUST TAKING CARE OF. MY.
GOING CHANDA HOW IMPORTANT
PUREDATA ITSELF FROM SIX MONTHS
TO OUR TWO YEAR SO.
THIS WHEN.
.
EXPAND THE.
A FINANCIAL OBLIGATION.
I KNOW TWO YEARS SHE SAW.
PROBABLY IMPORTANT PERIOD
THAT'S THE REASON YOU BAKED.
IT S. UP QUITE A JUMP FROM SIX
MONTHS TO TWO YEARS HAVE WHICH
IS THERE ANY.
.
BUT THE JUSTIFICATIONS YOU CAN
PROVIDE THE FULL RECOMMENDED FOR
TWO YEARS.
WHO CURRENT LAW THIS TWO YEARS?
THE CURRENT LAW ALLOWS YOU TO BE
EXEMPT.
IF THE CHILD IS UP TO TWO YEARS
IF THE CHILD IS ON THE TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS OLD.
YOU CAN BE EXEMPT FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE WELFARE TO
WORK PROGRAM AND WHILE YOU HAVE
TO DO. FIFTH ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS CALL UP THE WORKER AND ASK
THE WORKER. TO BE EXEMPT
AND THIS IS THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY WHERE NO LONGER CAN YOU
CALL THE WORKER IN A PICKUP WHEN
THEY TALK TO. YOU HAVE CALL
CENTERS
IT'S HARD TO REACH A WORKER.
SO PEOPLE DON'T GET IT'S THAT
THEY CANNOT THE AXIS THE WEALTH
OF SYSTEM TO BE EXEMPT SO THIS
SOME. SIMPLIFIES THE SYSTEM SO
IF YOU ARE EXEMPT AND IF YOU
WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
THE DUKE PARTICIPATE SO THAT
EXEMPTION IS AUTOMATIC YOU DON'T
HAVE TO ASK FOR IT.
DEBIT CITIZENS SO WHAT WHY HOW
THE STATE'S BEER HOW POINT IF
FOR A DOOR IS HAS EARNS OF SUCH
A LAW.
EXISTING LAW WHETHER I'M SORRY
YOU YOU SAID THOSE ALREADY LAW
REQUIRES A TWENTY FOUR YEAR AMID
A TWENTY. WITH THE EXCEPTION
PERIOD RIGHT BUT YOU HAVE TO
REQUEST THAT YOU HAVE TO OPT
INTO IT.
THEN BUT ANY E. HAVE TOOK. THEM
YEAH UP TO CALM UP ENOUGH TO
WORK AT THAT I WANNA BE EXEMPT.
THEY DON'T AUTOMATICALLY EXEMPT
YOU.
WE HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF THE
CHILDREN.
MONTH WITH KIDS UNDER TWENTY
FOUR MONTH OLD PARTICIPATING IN
THE WELFARE WORK PROGRAM.
AND LIVING THEIR BABIES AT HOME.
WITH SOMEBODY WHO ISN'T THROUGH
WHO THOUGHT.
WHO WHO DOESN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH THE CHILDREN?
IT BECAUSE THERE KNOW THAT THEY
COULD BE EXEMPT.
SO THIS BILL.
OUTBACK EXEMPTS OF THE PROGRAM.
MAKES A SIMPLE.
FOR THE CLIENT.
I'M IN NO WHEN THEY ARE IN NEED
TOUCH AND THEY SIMPLY ASK.
YEAH IT'S EASY TO ASPECT YOU
CALL UP THE WORK OF MAKE IT
SACRAMENTO YOU CALL UP EIGHT
SEVEN FOUR THREE TWO HUNDRED.
MEDICAL SOON BIG TREE. PHONE
TREE.
AND YOU PUT YOU ON THE PHONE SHE
FOR TWO THREE HOURS YOU COULD
EVER GET TO A WORKER.
IT'S NOT EASY.
BUT TWENTY YEARS AGO WAS IF YOU
CALLED UP THAT PICKED UP THE
PHONE AND SAY HI WOULD YOU WANT
OTHER BIG JUMPED OKAY FINE.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY
ANYMORE.
YOU HAVE WHERE YOU THEY HAVE BIG
CASELOADS. NOT ENOUGH WORKERS.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTION.
ARE THE DIRECT CLOSE IT THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
OKAY.
IT TOOK ON.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DUCKED AYE
CHOI AYE DOCTOR CHOI AND I'M
GONNA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN ADDRESS.
THIS AYE STONE.
STONE AYE THURMOND.
VILLAGE OUT FIVE ZERO.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE EFFECTIVE YEAH
GO AHEAD.
SO YES THANK YOU I'M TOO DAMN
PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE E.
THREE ARE WHICH ANNA INITIATES
FOSTER CARE FUNDING AT THE TIME
THAT THE FAMILY HAS MIGHT HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS REQUIRED IN
FEDERAL LAW.
AB TWENTY ONE AB THREE PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO RESOURCE PARENTS AND
THE CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE
THEREFORE. PREVENTING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FROM CAUSING FURTHER
TRAUMA TO THESE CHILDREN. THE
NEED FOR THIS FUNDING FIX FOR
THE RESOURCE FAMILIES CANNOT BE
AND.
UNDERSTATED THE R. F. A PROCESS
IS TAKING FAR LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED TO COMPLETE AND THE
AVERAGE FAMILY SPENDS WELL OVER
NINETY DAYS WAITING FOR
APPROVAL.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS ANGIE
SCHWARTZ A WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND CARE
GIVERS AND SELENA ALVAREZ WHO
CAN BOTH TESTIFY ABOUT HOW
PROBLEMATIC.
THESE DELAYS HAVE BEEN FOR
FAMILIES AND HOW GREAT OF A NEED
THERE IS TO INITIATE FUNDING AT
THE TIME OF POLICEMEN.
OKAY I.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SELENA
ALVAREZ AND I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA. ON MARCH SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AT ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE PM MY WIFE AND I
RECEIVED EMERGENCY PLACEMENT
EVER THREE NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
AGES SIX ELEVEN AND FIFTEEN THE
CHILDREN ARRIVED AT HER HOME
WITH ONLY THEIR SCHOOL BAGS IN
ONE BAG OF CLOTHING
THEY ARE IF A WORKER TOLD US SHE
WOULD START THE PROCESS FOR US
TO APPLY FOR YOLO COUNTY FOR CAL
WORKS IS NOT NEEDY RELATIVES AS
WE WERE NOT YET ARE IFFY
APPROVED.
TURNED OUT THAT INFORMATION WAS
INCORRECT SINCE WE LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO EVEN THE PLACEMENT IN
THE CHILDREN SERVICES WERE FROM
YELLOW COUNTY.
A MONTH LATER WE WERE TOLD TO
APPLY HONOR ON IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WHICH WE DID AND WE DID
NOT RECEIVE ANY RICHER PAYMENT
FOR THE FIRST MONTH.
WE STARTED OUR BE PROCESSED THE
FOLLOWING WEEK OF PLACEMENT
APPETITE MILLER COUNTY HAVE
THIRTY HOUR TRAINING
REQUIREMENT.
WHICH WE COMPLETED.
IN ADDITION TO OUR SUPER CLASS
AND. APPLICATION OF LIFE CAN BE
COMPLETED ALL ABOUT WITHIN SIX
WEEKS SIX WEEKS.
AFTER THAT WE WAITED AND WAITED
FOR WHAT FELT LIKE FOREVER
THERAPY THE RFA WORKER AT THE
TIME WAS EXTREMELY SWAMPED. IT
TOOK ABOUT THREE MONTHS FOR ME
TO HAVE MY IN PERSON INTERVIEW
AND ANOTHER MONTH FOR MY WIFE TO
HAVE HERS. WE'RE EVENTUALLY
APPROVED IN THE LAST WEEK OF
SEPTEMBER SIX MONTHS AFTER
PLACEMENT AND WE RECEIVED OUR
FIRST PAYMENT IN MID OCTOBER.
TAKING IN THREE CHILDREN FROM
KINDERGARTEN TO MINE TH GRADE IS
A HUGE FINANCIAL AND PERSONAL
UNDERTAKING. THE KIDS WERE
WORRIED THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
CHANGE SCHOOLS BUT WE ASSURED
THEM THEY WOULD NOT.
LUCKILY I WORKED IN WOODLAND SO
I WOULD TAKE THE KIDS TO TAKING
THE KIDS TO SCHOOL DAVIS WASN'T
COMPLETELY OUT OF THE WAY FOR
ME.
I DID NOTICE THAT MY GASOLINE
BILL HAS DOUBLED.
MY WIFE AND I HAD TO TAKE MANY
FINANCIAL SACRIFICE HAD TO MAKE
MANY SACRIFICES AND TAKE TIME
OFF FROM WORK IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT PITCHED THREE CHILDREN.
LIVING WITH US
MY WIFE DECIDED TO TAKE FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE ACT IN MID MARCH
FOR THE MAXIMUM OF THREE MONTHS
TO HELP ENSURE THE CHILDREN
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION INTO OUR
HOME.
HOWEVER FMLA ONLY PAYS ABOUT
FIFTY PERCENT OF YOUR EARNINGS
SO HER PAYMENTS FOR LOW.
I'M LUCKY ENOUGH TO WORK FOR A
NONPROFIT THAT VALUES FAMILY
TIME SO I WAS ABLE TO TAKE OFF.
AND USE MY SICK TIME TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR THE CHILDREN'S
APPOINTMENTS TWICE WEEKLY VISITS
THERAPY APPOINTMENTS MEDICAL
DENTAL AND COURT DATES.
ALTHOUGH WE MADE IT WORK IT
WASN'T WITHOUT A FINANCIAL TOLL.
BEING NOT THE YOUNGEST OF THE
KINDERGARTEN AND ONLY WENT TO
SCHOOL FROM ELEVEN AM TO THREE
PM. THIS PROVED TO BE A BIG
CHALLENGE.
WE WERE TOLD THAT THE CHILDCARE
SUBSIDY HAD RUN OUT FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR SO WE WOULD NEED TO
FIGURE OUT SOMETHING ELSE ON OUR
OWN AND PAY FOR CHILDCARE OUT OF
POCKET.
THE BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL CARE
WAS OUTRAGEOUSLY EXPENSIVE SO WE
OPTED FOR THE MORNING ONLY CARE
THREE DAYS A WEEK. IS COSTS FAR
EXCEEDED THE CAL WORKS ON THAT
WE RECEIVE FOR HIM BUT IT HAD TO
BE DONE.
WHEN SUMMER CAME AROUND WE HAVE
TO FIND CHILDCARE MY COWORKER
RECOMMENDED SUMMER CAMP TO THE
CITY.
BUT WE WERE ABLE TO GET
SCHOLARSHIPS THROUGH I FOSTER WE
STILL SPEND OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FROM THE KIDS TO
SUMMER CAMP.
I CONTINUE TO SEE THIS ISSUE
IMPACTING FAMILIES I WORK WITH
IN MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE. AS WELL
I WORK AS A SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIM ADVOCATE MY WORK WITH
FOSTER PARENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO TO LACK OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. THESE
FAMILIES ARE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BY TAKING THESE
CHILDREN AND.
AND IT ISN'T RIGHT OR FAIR FOR
THEM TO HAVE ZERO FINANCIAL
SUPPORT.
ESPECIALLY FOR ABOUT NOT
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
DON'T EVEN QUALIFY FOR CAL
WORKS.
TAKING PLACEMENT OF A CHILD WHO
HAS ALREADY UNDERGONE
OCCURRENCES OF ABUSE NEGLECT ON
AN EMERGENCY BASIS WHAT OUT
FOSTER CARE FUNDING PUTS
TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL STRAIN. ON
RELATIVES AND NON EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS.
WHO ARE?
TO ACCEPT THESE CHILDREN AS
EMERGENCY PLACEMENT.
SAY THAT'S A LONG SENTENCE
SORRY.
.
BUT BEFORE THE COMPLETION WHO
ACCEPT THAT THEIR CHILDREN
BEFORE THE COMPLETION OF OUR PAY
PROCESS.
ARE FULLY SUPPORTS.
LET'S SEE.
FINANCIAL PROCESSOR PRUNING.
BUT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY AND SHARE MY STORY.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO PASS
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE.
I ANTI TOWARDS POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS LOBBY REALLY BRIEF.
I KNOW THAT LAST MONTH THE
LEGISLATURE TOOK ACT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE ACTION TO STEM
THE CRISIS FACED BY THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES LIKE
SALINAS. UP FROM ACROSS THE
STATE WHO WERE CARING FOR
CHILDREN BEFORE APPROVAL AND NOT
RECEIVING ANY FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT INTERIM SOLUTION
EXPIRES ON JUNE THIRTIETH AND AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY THREE BUILT ON
THE SUCCESS OF THAT INTERIM
SOLUTION THAT USES THE SAME
MECHANISM. AND NOT INTERIM
SOLUTION IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
BECOMES THE LONG TERM SOLUTION
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE TAKEN IN
CHILDREN DOING EXACTLY WHAT WE
WANT THEM TO DO STEPPING UP
CARING FOR CHILDREN THAT NEED A
HOME. BEING THAT FAMILY MEMBER
AND FACING THE FINANCIAL CRISIS
THAT THOUSANDS OF OUR FAMILIES
HAVE FACED IT'S A NECESSARY FIX
IT TO GREAT EFFECT SO WE URGE
YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OKAY ANY OTHER PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT.
BONTA DABNEY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER OF CALIFORNIAN FULL
SUPPORT.
KELLY BUCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT PAYING CARE GIVERS
FROM THE TIME A PLACEMENT.
AND ARE WERE PLEASED WITH THE
SOLUTION AB ONE TEN.
THIS IS AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND.
WE APPRECIATE THE BILL
CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD TO
THE POLICY DISCUSSION CAN
CONTINUE TO OCCUR.
HI KATHY VAN AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH AND IN STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL.
ANY WITNESSES TO US ARE IN A
POSITION.
ANYONE WHO LEFT TO TESTIFY.
IN A POSITION.
NO.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
WHO HAD?
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS I'M T WAS SO MANY OF THE
FOSTER YOUTH AND WITH THOSE WHO
TOOK THEM AND AND. I WANT TO
THANK YOUR WITNESS FOR STEPPING
UP I APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOU BEAT ME
TO IT AND HAVE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORED COAUTHOR.
WITH
AND WE'VE ALREADY MOVED BILL.
ANY OTHER.
HAS BEEN ATTACKED QUITE THE
MISTER.
SO A THANK YOU ELSE CHAIR AT A
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL YOU KNOW WE ARE STATE
HAS A GREAT TRADITION OF TRYING
TO SUPPORT RESOURCE FAMILIES
AND.
OF LAST YEAR I DID A BILL THAT
FOCUS ON.
TRUCKER SUBSIDIES
FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES TO HELP
BUILD TO BUILD THE BRIDGE THAT
TO DO SIMILAR TO YOURS SIR.
ADDRESSING TIMING AND CHALLENGES
TO MAKE SURE THAT CHILDREN CAN
BE UNHEALTHY SUPPORTIVE
PLACEMENT SO THANK YOU. OTHERS
CONTINUES TO BE A CHALLENGING
INDEXING PROBLEM THANK YOU
PRIVILEGED APPEAR HAPPY TO
SUPPORT BILL.
AND IF.
OKAY.
A TABLE CLOSINGS DIFFERENT THANK
YOU I'M AT HIGH WE TALK ABOUT.
THIS ISSUE ALL THE TIME AND
JUST.
FIRST THAT SIX WHITE THERE'S
EIGHT HUNDRED KIDS RIGHT NOW IN
LA COUNTY THAT DON'T HAVE
PLACEMENT AND.
NOT BEING ABLE TO PAY THE
FAMILIES.
IT ADDS ANOTHER LAYER OF BURDEN
TO THOSE FAMILIES ARE WILLING TO
STEP UP AND SOME OF THEM DON'T
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT SO
THIS WILL HELP.
ENSURE THAT SOME OF THESE KIDS
GET PLACEMENT AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE YOU'RE
ABLE.
OKAY MOTION HAS BEEN MADE. ON
MANY PAST USE OF COURSE TO OUR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
DEPELCHIN INFORMATION HE
SETTING.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE DOCTOR CHOI
GUY THAT YOU CHOI AYE AT NUMBER
LEFT.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN EYES RARES.
DAIS AYE STONE.
STONE I BERMAN. THURMOND AYE
BILLS THAT SIX
.
I THINK YOU THAT DOT THE ALL OF
THE BILLS WE ARE.
OPENING.
THE ROLE FOR ADD ONS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER ONE IN THE NINETEEN
THIRTY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE TO
PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER IF TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN A TO ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MANAGE TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS. ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN A BETWEEN NINE OH FIVE
O'CLOCK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACOSTA
DO PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A BETWEEN
NINE THIRTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE A. B. THIRTY NINETY
EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN DO
PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS.
ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I VEGAS.
VEGAS I.
ITEM NUMBER TO A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ARAMBULA THURMAN.
THURMOND TIME.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY ONE
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK DO
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE GLASS.
BASED AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ARAMBULA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
VEGAS.
THERE'S AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE HE BE TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OF
AMBER LEFT.
ARAMBULA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE DAIS.
THERE'S AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX A BETWEEN ONE
EIGHTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO THAT I'M GONNA. BUT I'M
GLAD I.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE.
I MEAN I'M SORRY.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I THURMOND.
THEY'RE MEANT I.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I
TO DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
DAIS.
REYES I.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUT
KALRA DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ARAMBULA.
ASSEMBLY I.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY SIX
OH FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
NINE SIXTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN THE MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CLUB MEMBER LEFT.
ARAMBULA HI MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB THREE
ZERO ZERO SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE.
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AND I.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B..
THREE ZERO THREE THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN ARAMBULA.
BUT I'M GLAD I THURMOND.
WE YEAH. REQUIREMENT I.
I DON'T KNOW NOT I'M ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN A. B. THIRTY THIRTY
NINE SIMILAR HOLDEN DO PASSED
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY MAYBE THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ARAMBULA NUMBER LEVINE
MAIENSCHEIN.
YES SIR.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
DAIS.
VARIOUS AYE.
BUT WE WERE TWENTY TWO IS FILLED
PULLED UP CLOSE BY THE AUTHOR I
TO ME BUT TWENTY THREE A. B.
TOOK THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN. BUT I'M
WILL LEFT.
ARAMBULA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING.
AND WHAT.
AND.
HE'S OF CONSENT.
BECAUSE. THAT WAS THE.
BUT WITH ON CONSENT WAS PUT ON.
OKAY I'M.
I READ THEM ALL OF.
AND CONSENT CALENDAR.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
A BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY
MATHIS DO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT I'M GONNA.
ASSEMBLY LINE. ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AB TWENTY ONE ELEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK DO PASSED
THE APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HIGH.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR BETWEEN ONE
FIFTY TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I.
WORK AND WRITTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WORD TURNED
ACT FOR FOR TWENTY FIVE